Is everybody keeping cool today?
It's really hot outside.
Super hot.
Sticking sweat.
Yeah, it's really good.
It's like, you just sweat looking at it.
I'm just so hot right now.
It's so gross.
大家今天都挺凉快的吧？外面真的很热。超级热。汗流浃背的。对，真的很棒。简直就是，你光看一眼都会流汗。我现在太热了。太恶心了。
Hey, is there a back end to your fucking joke?
No, just wanted to say hi, it's hot outside?
What kind of cold open is this?
It's a hot open.
Welcome to Smartless.
Smartless.
JPM, I'm across the street from you.
Yeah, no.
喂，你那破笑话还有后半句吗？没有，就想打个招呼，外面很热？这是什么冷开场啊？这是热开场。欢迎来到 SmartLess。SmartLess。JPM，我就在你街对面。对，没有。
I know.
What do you mean?
So wait, so you're up top, right?
All the way up top.
I'm at top.
Did you ask?
What was the question?
Sorry.
我知道。什么意思？等等，所以你在顶楼对吧？最顶楼。我在顶楼。你问了吗？什么问题？对不起。
Yeah.
Okay.
So I think I can see you.
You can see me.
I'm not in the window.
Wait, are you being serious?
Can you see the scaffolding?
Yeah.
对。好吧。所以我想我能看到你。你能看到我。我不在窗户边。等等，你是认真的吗？你能看到脚手架吗？对。
What's going on up there?
Are we doing some remod?
Do you see like a black bag on the scaffolding that's blowing in the wind?
No.
Because I'm on the south side of the building.
South side of your building.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
So on the south side of the building,
上面在干嘛？我们在搞装修吗？你看到脚手架上有个黑色袋子在风中飘扬吗？没有。因为整栋楼都挂着网，所以我看不到那个。哦，你透过网看不见。对，我看不到。不管怎样，我们是邻居。我们从来没住得这么近过。我知道。
way up there, there's like a little black bag.
No, because the whole building is netted,
so I don't see that.
Oh, you don't see through the netting.
No, I don't.
Anywho, so we're neighbors.
We've never lived closer to one another.
I know.
其实，不对，那次你和我还有我妻子一起住在我的房子里。太有趣了。为什么我的小女儿长得那么像你？这是在生孩子之前，天哪，你们的地板太嘎吱作响了，我当时晚上总是，就觉得，我蹑手蹑脚走动时不想发出一点声音。哦，香烟。我那时候也抽烟来着，对吧？
Actually, no, that when you lived in my house with me and my wife.
That was so fun.
Why does my youngest daughter look so much like you?
This is before the kids, and the, God, your floors are so creaky,
and I was just always, like, at night, just like,
I didn't want to make a sound as I snuck around.
Oh, cigarettes.
I was smoking back then, too, though, wasn't I?
你当然抽了。嘿，你的头发怎么剪成这样？对，看起来很酷。我刚修了一小下，Tremski。埃利现在跟你在一起吗？没有，我没看到埃利。我是去看我的好兄弟，我的哥们儿，凯文·温恩了。等等，你跟埃利吵架了吗？
You sure were.
Hey, why is your hair so cut?
Yeah, it looks cool.
I just had a little Tremski.
Is Eli with you right now?
No, I didn't see Eli.
I went to see my boy, my guy, Kevin Woon.
Why, wait, are you in a fight with Eli?
不，不，不，我只是没见过埃利。还有……你和埃利怎么了？没有。好吧……我爱埃利，你知道的，如果你……所以，等等。现在肖恩也有了私人发型师。
No, no, no, I just haven't seen Eli.
And, uh...
What happened to Eli and you?
No.
Well...
I love Eli, you know, if you're like...
So, wait.
Now, Sean also has a personal hairdresser.
肖恩，你的，你有了新的人选，你的发型师是谁？对，他叫马科斯。嘿，#太有共鸣了，你们两个都有私人发型师？不，不是，不是私人。他们不是全职雇员，你这个混蛋。对，某种程度上是。薪水，没有。谁给你剪头发？
Sean, who's your, you've got a new person, who's your person?
Yeah, his name is Marcos.
Hey, hashtag relatable, you both have personal hairdressers?
No, it's the, no, it's not personal.
They're not full-time employment, you jerk.
Yeah, kind of.
The payroll, no.
Who cuts your hair?
不管我正在做什么项目，哪个项目的发型部门负责人就找谁。那是谎言。事实上，她刚刚离开公寓。她就是那个项目的首席发型师，对，。而且她还来过家里，是吧？她来了。你这次根本不在演员阵容里。你是导演。
Whoever is heading the hair department on whatever project I'm working.
That's a lie.
As a matter of fact, she just left the apartment.
She is the key hairdresser on the, yeah.
And she came over to the house, huh?
She did.
You're not even in the cast this time.
You're the director.
所以她不得不来导演的住所。所以现在谁在给……这太做作了。在那些高雅的人面前太做作了。我正在拍一个小场景，这有资格享受免费剪发。他的腿断了，所以他不能来找我。所以我得去曼哈顿高级地段的导演公寓。好吗？
so she had to come to the director's out.
So now who's high...
That's so inky.
That's so in front of those high pollutant.
I'm doing one small scene which qualifies as a free cut.
His legs are broken so he couldn't come to me.
So I had to go to the director's apartment down in fancy part of Manhattan.
Okay?
所以，肖恩，你很喜欢你的新发型师？我很喜欢。他真的非常非常厉害。马科斯，对。以至于你都不肯脱下帽子。对，把头拿下来。让我们看看马可把你弄成什么样了。好吧，只是，你知道的，看起来……
So, Sean, you're enjoying your new hairdresser?
I am.
He's really, really good.
Marcos, yeah.
So much so that you won't take your hat off.
Yeah, take your head off.
Let's see what Marco is doing to you.
Well, it's just, you know, look like...
戴上。戴上？就像威尔说的那样，看起来像个童子军发型。我没这么说。我只是说看起来你的头发是粘上去的。周六晚上，你说我看起来像个童子军。哦，周六。我说，你当时是想扮……什么科学家？疯狂科学家？因为你的头发……
Back on. Back on?
Like Will said it looked like a page boy.
I didn't say that. I just said it looked like your hair is attached.
On Saturday night, you said I looked like a page boy.
Oh, on Saturday.
And I said, were you going for...
What scientist? Mad scientist?
Because your hair was...
我的头发更长，因为都翘起来了。你当时说，你是对他们说“给我整一个疯狂科学家”吗？是的。所以，威尔，你得……这就是我剪头发的原因，因为肖恩让我觉得羞愧。真的吗？还是只是一种夏天的……或者你……
My hair was longer, because it was all sticking out.
And you said, did you say, did you just say to them give me the mad scientist?
Yes.
And so, Will, you've got to...
That's why I cut my hair because Sean shamed me.
Is that true?
Or is it just like a summer sort of...
Or you...
是游泳队的吗？剪这么短看起来真不错。好吧，你知道吗，我真不敢相信你在该死的播客里习惯性地嚼口香糖。我知道，我是说我很紧张，只是他，这并不是，顺便说一句，我这种嚼法声音并不大。你在这方面有进步，但还是会穿帮，我敢替罗布和贝内特说一句，时不时得把你的麦克风静音真的很烦人。贝内特，罗布，告诉我，是不是这样？我们把它处理一下，你知道吗，你知道人们有尼古丁。我和贝内特、罗布有着特殊的联系，他们可能爱我。还有尼古丁。你知道吗？
is it swim team it looks good short like that well you know what i can't believe that you would
habitually chew gum on a fucking podcast i know i mean i'm nervous just he just it wasn't by the way it's
not loud the way i'm doing it you've gotten better at that but it still sneaks through and i'll bet
you all speak for rob and benet right here it's getting annoying having to mute your microphone every
once in a while benet rob tell me is it true we tidy it up you know what you know what people have nicotine
I have a special relationship with Bennett, Rob, who may love me.
And nicotine.
You know what?
我们今天的咖啡聊天超级亢奋。确实。我觉得是我的错。我喜欢这样。我现在也在喝一杯。我正在喝罕见的下午1点咖啡。我们进入了真正的雷吉斯和凯茜·李的领域。我们很幸运。
Our coffee chat's real hyper today.
It is.
I think it's my fault.
I love it.
I'm having one now, too.
I'm having the rare 1 p.m. coffee.
We're in a real Regis and Kathy Lee areas.
We're lucky.
有幸能参与其中。好了。你们想继续吗？对。我是说，我不知道。你想为你的开场白做个铺垫吗？对。你们呢？
Lucky to be associated.
All right.
Do you want to get on with it?
Yeah.
I mean, I don't know.
Do you want to tee up your intro?
Yeah.
How about you guys?
我们在这里进行一个官方的嘉宾环节吧，好吧，好吧，好吧，好吧，让我们看看你们能不能猜出来，好吗，好吧，太棒了，嗯，加入我们胡闹的这个人是一位还没满40岁但他的乐队已经快接近20年大关的家伙，好吧，他们是格莱美奖得主，他们享誉世界，深受喜爱，他在加州出生但在英国长大，他和他的妻子有三个孩子，他的妻子曾作为嘉宾上过这个播客节目。我知道是谁，快他妈说出来，是，嗯，克里斯·马丁。不，不。是马库斯·芒福德。完全正确。
Let's have an official guest.
session here okay okay okay okay let's see if you guys can guess it all right okay great um joining our nonsense
today is a fellow who's not yet 40 but is already approaching the 20 year mark with his band okay
they are Grammy winners they are known and loved worldwide he was born in california but raised in
England he's got three children with his wife who has been a guest on this very podcast I know
who it is let's fucking hear it it's um Chris Martin no no
It's Marcus Mumford.
Bingo.
滚开。怎么样？这个嘉宾怎么样？你怎么知道的？因为他是个聪明人。马库斯，我喜欢我的提示。我能继续我的提示吗？不，你的提示太糟糕了。
Get out.
How about that?
How about that for a guest?
How did you know that?
Because he's a smart person.
Marcus, I liked my hints.
Can I get on with my hands?
No, your hints were terrible.
我不知道他是在加州出生的。好吧，但他的乐队听起来像个专门搞人身伤害的律师事务所。你甚至都没说出来？人身伤害。听起来确实像。听起来像个管道公司。Monfort in time。确实。
I didn't know where he's born in California.
Well, but his band sounds like a family, law firm specializing personal injury.
You didn't even say it?
Personal injury.
It does sound like.
It sounds like a plumbing company.
Monfort in time.
It does.
那是故意的，对吧，马库斯？不，但是马库斯，我知道我只是在说……我为纪录片感到无比兴奋，我10分钟前还在谈论你，太兴奋能来看它了。耶，你会来吗？是的，老兄，你会来的。哦，太棒了，就在街对面。我可能，我可能
That was on purpose, right, Marcus?
No, but Marcus, I knew I was just.
talking about I'm so excited for the doc
and I was just talking about you
10 minutes ago so excited to come and see it
yeah are you gonna come yeah man
are you gonna come oh sweet it's just down
the street I might I might
要工作，但我可能能赶上。我想我妻子会去的，这才是任何人真正在乎的，她是我的女伴。你们有没有在嘉宾揭晓之前根据他们的笑声猜出过嘉宾是谁？因为我真的很……他们把我吓坏了，老兄。
be working but I might be able to make it
I think my wife will be there which
that's all anybody ever cares about she's my date
have you ever
guest a guest
from their laugh
before they've done the reveal
because I was really they freak me out man
你们的家伙把我吓坏了，他们就像是，别呼吸。哦，真的吗？直到揭晓。我很想笑，因为你们非常搞笑。他们让你觉得我们像是那种容易暴怒的人吗？就像如果我们听到嘉宾的声音？
your guys freak
me out there like, don't breathe.
Oh, really?
Until the reveal.
And I wanted to laugh because you're very funny.
Did they make you think that we're
like, that we're prone to rage?
Like if we hear the guest?
不，他们让我觉得，你知道，以一种非常礼貌的方式，如果我……确保……就会毁了整个节目。太逊了。整个惊喜环节完全是个浪费。这只是省得我们做功课了。而且观众已经知道他是谁了。
No, they made me feel, you know, in a very polite way,
like I would ruin the entire show if I
in sure.
It's squeak.
The whole surprise thing is so,
it's such a waste. It just saves us
from doing homework. And the audience
already knows who it is.
我们是仅有的两个在剧集上线时还不知道嘉宾是谁的混蛋。我不敢相信你把我叫做混蛋。但是听着，这很有趣。我们玩得很开心。好吧，杰森。有趣，研究一下。好吧。
We're the only two dicks that don't know who the guest is,
the time the episode is up.
I don't dare you refer to me as the dick.
But listen, it's fun.
We're having fun.
Okay, Jason.
Fun, look into it.
Okay.
马库斯，欢迎来到 SmartLess。是时候了。我真的，我发自内心地，我很早就上了 SmartLess。我很早就来了。你来过我们在洛杉矶的演出。我记得你和我，我们一起去看了《音乐大师》的早期试映。我们去了，对。你说，而且那是，
Marcus, welcome to SmartList.
It's about time.
I'm so, I'm genuinely so on, I was early on Smartis.
I was very early.
You came, you came to the show in L.A.
I remember you and I, we went to an early screening of Maestro together.
We did, yeah.
And you said, and it was, it was really,
就在我们演出之后，你说，我来到演出时说，我太惊讶了。那是你们拍摄的那天，非常忙碌。等等，你是说洛杉矶的演出吗？对。在纪录片里？对，对，对。
right after our show and you said, I came to the show
and I said, I was so surprised.
It was the night you guys were filming
and it was really hectic.
Wait, was it, you mean like the L.A. show?
Yeah.
In the dock?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
市中心那个。对，对，对，对。在剧院。我不记得叫什么名字了。我不想打扰你，因为当时超级忙。但是的，我来看了演出。而且我，我听你们的节目
The one downtown.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
At the theater.
I can't remember what it's called.
And I didn't want to bother you
because it was super hectic.
But yes, I came to the show.
And I've been, but I've been listed your show
已经很久了。太疯狂了。你准备好接受意见了吗？你有什么意见吗？你会怎么做？如果是我们，你会怎么改变？我们正在寻求改进。你知道吗？我觉得那个“hash shit”是个低谷。对。这是一个，全都是低谷。我们所做的就是，我们很早就把标准定得很低，对吧？然后一切都感觉像是一场胜利。唯一的出路就是向上。我喜欢这样。非常舒适。我喜欢。
for a very long time.
It's crazy.
You're ready for notes.
Do you have any news?
notes. What would you do? If you were us, how would you change it?
We're looking to improve. You know what? Here the hash shit was a low point I think.
Yeah. It's a, it's all low points. What we do is, what we do is we establish the bar low early, right?
And then everything feels like a win. The only way is up. I love it. It's just very cozy. I love it.
我告诉你一件事，马克，有趣的是，你提出了一个话题，我们正准备从主题上延续这个话题，那就是你告诉我你当时在现场。我想，你告诉我你当时在现场。我依稀记得当时好像说过，我希望你打个招呼，然后你刚才提到当时很忙，你不想打招呼，你来看我们的演出却没有去后台打招呼
I tell you something, Mark, what's interesting, you brought up something and we're about to tap into a runner
thematically is that you told me that you were at the show. And I think, you told me that you were at the show.
and I vaguely remember at the time
sort of saying, I wish you had said hi
and then you just mentioned it was hectic
and you didn't want to say hi
you came to our show
and didn't come backstage and say hi
而杰森对此有想法。等等，这不是百老汇剧院。是的，我们直奔主题吧。我需要你对此发表意见。这和……我去看了……你知道我上周去埃克塞特看谁了吗？
and Jason has thoughts on this
Hold on this is
we're not talking Broadway theater
Yeah let's do it right
I need your opinion on this
It's adjacent
I went to see
Do you know who I went to see last week
是蒂姆·基。你知道蒂姆·基吗？哦，对，他太棒了。他是我最喜欢的喜剧演员之一，我觉得他是个天才。我去看了他的演出，正准备离开时心想，现在他知道我来了，他还帮忙搞到了票。就这么走掉太粗鲁了。
in Exeter was Tim Key
Now do you know Tim Key?
Oh yeah he's brilliant
He's one of my favorite comics of all time
I think he's a genius.
I went and watched his show and was about to leave and thought to myself,
now he knows I'm here, he helped with the tickets.
It is rude to leave.
嗯，那不一样。如果有人帮你拿到了票。没错。不留下一句“精彩的演出”就走。那这样吧，对吧？所以你是一位音乐人，你在现场场馆和剧院演出。所以有很多名人经常来看你的演出。来了。
Well, that's different.
If someone has helped you with the ticket.
Amen.
Without saying great show.
So how about this, right?
So you are a musician and you are in live venues and theaters.
And so there are some famous people that come see your shows a lot.
Here we go.
同样的规则在那里适用吗？你知道谁在里面吗？如果他们没有去后台说“嘿，演出太棒了”，你会生气吗？不。音乐界的文化截然不同。非常不同。骨子里我更像是个摇滚乐手，伙计们。等等，你的立场是什么，杰森？
Does the same rule apply there?
Are you aware who's in there?
Are you offended if they don't come back and say, hey, great show?
No.
Culturally very different in music.
Very different.
I'm more of a rock and roll guy at heart, guys.
Wait, what's your position, Jason?
你是不露面的人吗？你去看演出是不去后台的人吗？我认为观众中那些有名甚至有点名气的人会觉得，哦，既然我们同为名人，他们就会欢迎我去了后台打招呼，这太自以为是了。这就像是太傲慢了。滚开得了。这更像是你可能想见我
Are you a no show?
Are you a no show at the show?
I think it's presumptuous for people in the audience who are famous or even pseudo-famous
to think that, oh, they'll be welcome backstage just because you share fame.
to come say hi.
It's just like it's so arrogant.
Like just get hell out.
It's more like you probably want to see me
因为我真的很有名，所以我要用我的存在来赐福于你。对，并让你知道我觉得你有多棒。或者觉得不咋地。或者谈谈节目有多棒，或者灯光，或者找点礼貌的话说。麦当娜纪录片《真相或大胆》里有个著名的片段，凯文·科斯特纳去了后台。你看到了吗？
because I'm really famous, so I'll bless you with my presence.
Yeah, and let you know how great I think you were.
Or not.
Or talk about how great the program was, or the lighting,
or find something polite to say.
There's that famous clip from the Madonna documentary Truth or Dare
when Kevin Costner comes backstage.
Did you see that?
他说，对，我觉得，而她刚刚演了三个小时。她大汗淋漓，你知道的，为5000人表演。然后他说，他觉得，对，我们觉得这真的很整洁。对，对。她转向镜头说，任何把我的演出叫作“整洁”的人都得滚。就在他们面前。不，他走了，然后在镜头前说，啊，就这样。
And he goes, yeah, I thought,
and she just spent three hours.
She's drenched in sweat, you know, performing for 5,000 people.
And he goes, he says, yeah, we thought it was really neat.
Yeah, yeah.
And she turns to the camera, she goes, anybody who calls my show neat has got to go.
Right in front of them.
No, he left and she goes, ah, like that on camera.
我最喜欢的这种后台时刻是当我被非常明确地邀请去后台时，那是在肯德里克·拉马尔在博纳罗音乐节演出之后，
My favorite backstage moment like that when I was invited, very explicitly invited backstage,
was after Kendrick Lamar played Bonnery.
and there was a sort of message
that came down from on high
that Kendrick would like to see you
and when Kendrick calls you come
right because he's the king
I learned that lesson the hard way
高层传下某种消息说肯德里克想见你，当肯德里克召唤你时，你得马上过去，因为他是国王。我用惨痛的教训学到了这一点。
and it was like you can go in now
and
and he took off almost all of his clothes
as I walked in it was amazing
it sounds more like boneroo
we'll be right back after these messages
it was amazing and I thought
like the gum the gumption you know the gumption to be like yeah come on back after the show and it'll be
然后就像是你可以进去了，当我走进去时，他脱掉了几乎所有的衣服，这太惊人了。这听听更像是博纳罗音乐节。我们在这些广告之后马上回来。这太惊人了，我想就像是那份勇气，你知道，那种敢于说“嘿，演出后来后台吧，这将是
the very moment when i take all my clothes off and i'm just down to my undies it's confident we'll have a
chat i don't know i kind of feel but but aren't you comfortable with that like like even on a on a tv set
or a film set or whatever people knock on my trailer i'm like come in i'm dressing i don't care it is a
dressing room yeah yeah yeah that is you know marcus you bring up uh tim kee whom i also adore and he did that
incredible film with your wife.
Did.
The Ballad of Wallace Island, which I
loved that film.
我脱光所有衣服、只剩一条内裤的那个准确时刻”的勇气。这很自信，我们要聊一聊。我不知道，我有点觉得……但是，难道你不习惯那样吗？就像在电视片场或电影片场或其他地方，人们敲我的房门，我说“进来吧，我在换衣服，我不在乎”。这就是个化妆间，对吧，对，那是，你知道的，马库斯，你提到了蒂姆·基，我也很崇拜他，他和你的妻子拍了那部不可思议的电影。拍了。我超爱的那部电影《华莱士岛的民谣》。
I did too.
Brilliant, brilliant film, wasn't it?
We're not going to get into Carrie's
career, but it, I mean,
amazing.
Good, because I haven't seen a lot of it, but that one I've seen
three times.
I love that one so much.
我也很喜欢。精彩绝伦的电影，不是吗？我们不打算深入探讨凯瑞的职业生涯，但它，我是说，太棒了。太好了，因为我没看过多少她的作品，但那部我看了三遍。我太喜欢那部了。
So, me too. You guys, I urge
anybody to see The Ballad of Wallace Island.
It's such a beautiful little film.
It's so funny and poignant and just
amazing, beautiful, beautiful film.
Well, I got so into Tim's
podcast. He's got like a radio
for, it's not a podcast, it's a radio
所以，我也一样。伙计们，我强烈建议任何人去看《华莱士岛的民谣》。这是一部非常美丽的小电影。既搞笑又辛酸，简直是一部惊艳、美丽、美丽的电影。我太迷蒂姆的播客了。他有一个广播，这不是播客，这是一个广播
show in the UK on
public radio and I got so
deeply into it in COVID that when he
wrote to Kerry with a script I was like
you absolutely have to do this movie
he's, him and Tom Bazden together
are phenomenal.
Tom Baden amazing too. Yeah,
节目，在英国的公共广播电台，我在疫情期间迷得太深了，以至于当他带着剧本写信给凯瑞时，我就想，你绝对得拍这部电影。他和汤姆·巴斯登在一起简直太出色了。汤姆·巴斯登也很棒。对，
amazing. And just for my sister, your
wife is Carrie Mulligan. Just so for Tracy
my sister in case she doesn't know. Hi Tracy.
Tracy almost crashed
She was trying to look at all.
You know.
Hey, Siri.
She's pulling into Kohler, Wisconsin
太棒了。顺便替我妹妹说一句，你的妻子是凯瑞·穆里根。为了让我妹妹特蕾西知道，以防她不知道。嗨，特蕾西。特蕾西差点撞车。她当时正试图看所有的。你知道的。嘿，Siri。她正开着车驶入威斯康星州的科勒，
with her phone in her head.
Wait, so Marcus, getting back to that for one quick second,
she can't possibly see all your shows
because you're playing almost every night.
No, she actually broke a record.
So are you allowed to not see all of hers?
Yeah, yeah, she came on tour.
I think she, in one year, maybe was at.
手里还拿着手机。等等，马库斯，回到那个话题一小会儿，她不可能看你所有的演出，因为你几乎每天晚上都在演出。不，她其实打破了一个记录。所以你被允许不去看她所有的演出吗？对，对，她跟着巡演了。我想她，在一年里，可能去过
48 shows
and watched
two.
Not the whole thing.
Top and tail.
Yeah.
She really
she really
48场演出，看了两场。也不是全部。只看开头和结尾。对。她真的，她真的
she says she likes our
band, our recorded music.
There's some caveats.
First time she saw our band play
she thought we were quite shouty.
And to be fair, I think she's right about that.
But then, you know, she's put up
with it for a long time. But then, yeah,
说她喜欢我们的乐队，我们录制的音乐。有一些保留意见。她第一次看我们乐队演出时，觉得我们有点太吵了。平心而论，我觉得她说的没错。但随后，你知道的，她忍受了很长时间。但接着，是的，
She doesn't feel like if she's on the road
She has to come to every show
Wait Marcus, did you guys meet at summer camp?
Am I right about that?
Yeah, we met at Bible camp
Yeah, when we were like,
I was 10, she was 12.
What?
她觉得如果她在路上，她不需要去看每一场演出。等等，马库斯，你们是在夏令营认识的吗？我没记错吧？对，我们在圣经夏令营认识的，对，当时我们大约，我10岁，她12岁。什么？
Nice, wow, yeah, nice.
So you guys were, now she started to tell some of the story
I think I remember when she was on about her.
They were pen pals, right?
Yeah, you guys were pen pals.
Yeah, and she still has the journal entry
from the day we met where my cousin was there
who was two years older,
太好了，哇，对，太好了。所以你们当时，现在她开始讲述了一部分故事，我想我记得当她在节目上讲述关于她的事情时。他们是笔友，对吧？对，你们是笔友。对，她现在还留着我们相遇那天的日记，当时我表哥也在场，他比我大两岁，
who was age appropriate for her,
and he got a eight and a half out of ten.
But I, who was definitely not underlined boyfriend material, got a nine out of ten.
Wow.
Go figure.
So then what made you not boyfriend material because you were just...
I was two years younger and I was also a foot shorter.
Oh, it wasn't because you were some...
对她来说年龄正合适，他得了8.5分（满分10分）。而我，绝对不是那种在日记里被划重点的“男朋友人选”，却得了9分。哇。真没想到。那是什么让你不属于男朋友人选，因为你只是……我小两岁，而且我还矮了一英尺。哦，不是因为你是个……
It wasn't because you were a monster running around and being a pair of years.
No, well, she did write in her journal that I was a bit aggressive
on the soccer pitch
that I've gone in a bit heavy on some of the tackles
which lines up
but then we stayed in touch as kids
I guess and then we reconnected in our 20s
and did you lighten up are you still a heavy tackler
不是因为你是个四处乱跑的怪胎吗？不，好吧，她在日记里确实写过我在足球场上有点太具有侵略性了，我在有些铲球时动作有点过猛，这倒是挺符合事实的。但后来我们作为小孩子保持着联系，我想，然后在我们20多岁时重新取得了联系。你收敛了吗？你现在还是个凶猛的铲球手吗？
or I mean let's
yes
it's one of the few times I'll drop a sea bomb
in earnest
is co-ed soccer in the states particularly
I lived in Denver
and I used to play co-ed soccer
and you know you can't retaliate
或者，我的意思是，让我们……这是我真正爆粗口的少数几次之一，美国的男女混合足球，尤其是我住在丹佛的时候，我过去常常踢男女混合足球，你知道你不能报复，
at least where I come from
you know a woman tackles you really hard
you can't retaliate
so yeah I get
yeah so the rage comes out on the football field
sometimes
oh god
it's a big big game on right now
至少在我来自的地方，你知道一个女人狠狠地铲你，你不能报复，所以，是的，我明白了，所以这种愤怒有时会在足球场上爆发。哦，天哪，现在正在进行一场非常非常大的比赛。
Willie I bet you're taking you
I know I know I'm guys whoever organized this
I know I can't believe we've done this
I know I'm watching it I've got it too
I just turned it off
but don't spoil it right
because I haven't
I'm going to watch it afterwards.
威利，我打赌你在看……我知道，我知道，伙计们，不管是谁组织了这个，我知道，我简直不敢相信我们做了这个。我知道我在看。我也有，我刚刚把它关掉了，但别剧透，好吗？因为我还没看，我打算稍后再看。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's really intriguing right now, by the way.
It's really intriguing.
I haven't got a live feed because I was thinking about it.
And then I didn't press record.
Should we take a break?
Are you in the UK?
Marcus, are you in the UK or are you here?
对，对，对，对。顺便说一句，现在真的非常吸引人。我没有直播源，因为我刚才在考虑。然后我没按录音。我们应该休息一下吗？你在英国吗？马库斯，你在英国还是在这里？
Yeah, and so I thought on Champions League Final Day,
we'd be safe to do a chat at 5 or 6.
Turns out it was an early kickoff.
5 o'clock.
But do you honestly want to take a two-second break and go hit record
so you can see the second half?
I'll
Do it on your phone, yeah, for sure
对，所以我想在欧冠决赛日，我们可以在5点或6点安全地进行聊天。结果发现这是一场早场比赛。5点。但你老实说想花两秒钟休息一下去按录音，这样你就能看下半场了吗？我……在你的手机上弄，对，没问题。
No, no, no, no
Don't worry about it
It's fine
If it was an England game
So we have a
We have a fairly new management team
Last couple years
And who's we?
不，不，不，不。别担心。没关系。如果是一场英格兰的比赛……所以我们有一个……我们有一个相当新的管理团队，最近几年。谁的“我们”？
They haven't managed us through a...
They haven't managed
Sorry, band management
Oh, okay
They haven't managed our band
Through a World Cup summer
And it's a big deal
Trying to manage
他们没有带领我们度过……他们没有带领……抱歉，乐队管理层。哦，好吧。他们没有带领我们的乐队度过一个世界杯的夏天。而试图管理
Our band during a World Cup summer
Because if there's any kind of
We tend not to play on England days
Because they're big days
I take this stuff very seriously.
And I sat them all down for the third time in about February.
We delayed the announcement of our tour
because they hadn't yet announced what dates and days
在世界杯夏天期间我们的乐队是一件大事，因为如果有任何……我们倾向于不在英格兰比赛的日子演出，因为那是大日子。我对这种事非常严肃。大约在2月份，我第三次把他们所有人都召集起来坐下。我们推迟了巡演的宣布，因为他们当时还没有宣布小组赛的日期和天数。
the group games were going to be.
And so business-wise, it was almost a disaster.
But we waited for so long
because we waited to announce the tour
so that we knew we weren't going to be on stage
when England were playing, right?
And I sat everyone down.
I said, look, guys, management's going great.
所以从商业角度来看，这几乎是一场灾难。但我们等了很久，因为我们推迟宣布巡演是为了确保当英格兰比赛时我们不会在舞台上，对吧？我让每个人都坐下。我说，听着，伙计们，管理工作进展得很顺利。
You're doing a really good job.
But just so you know,
we've had this conversation now three times.
I'm deadly serious.
If you double book us when England are playing,
everyone is fired.
Everyone is fired.
And I think they've got the message pretty clear now.
你们干得真的很好。但为了让你们知道，我们现在已经谈过这件事三次了。我是认真的。如果你们在我们英格兰比赛时给我们双倍预定演出，所有人都会被解雇。所有人都会被解雇。我想他们现在已经很清楚这个信息了。
And I think I'm going to manage to sneak to a couple of games.
But it's a big summer.
It's a big summer.
Yeah.
So let's go back to being a kid.
And we're right in there around summer camp.
Where did you grow up?
Jason said you grew up in California?
我想我能设法溜去看几场比赛。但这是一个盛大的夏天。这是一个盛大的夏天。对。所以让我们回到童年，我们就回到夏令营的时候。你在哪里长大的？杰森说你在加州长大的？
No, I was born in California.
Oh, you're born, okay.
But evacuated to England at six months old.
Oh, so not even.
And I grew up in London.
What were the conditions under which you were born in California?
Why is that?
My parents were working there for a couple of years down in Anaheim for a church.
不，我是在加州出生的。哦，你是出生在，好吧。但在六个月大时撤退到了英国。哦，所以甚至都不算。我在伦敦长大的。你在加州出生的背景是什么？为什么会这样？我父母在那里为阿纳海姆的一个教会工作了几年。
And so I was born, I popped up along the way.
And then they came back home to plant a church in London from the Californian one.
God, and then at what point then was me?
music introduced to you?
Yeah, I mean, it was the kitchen.
My mom listened to a lot of music and had a vinyl collection that I was allowed access to quite early on.
And then we would listen to music.
What were some of those vinals?
所以我就顺理成章地出生在那里。然后他们回到家乡，用加州的那个教会为基础在伦敦建立一个教会。天哪，那是什么时候开始接触音乐的？对，我是说，从厨房开始的。我妈妈听很多音乐，有一个黑胶唱片收藏，我挺小的时候就被允许去接触它们。然后我们就听音乐。那些黑胶唱片都有什么？
What was a lot of classical music and a lot of choral music?
Because she was in a choir at university and stuff.
That's cool.
And then the only two kind of pop records she had or non-classical records were Blood on the Tracks.
Amazing.
And House of the Rising Sun by the Animals.
Wow.
Oh, wow.
有很多古典音乐和很多合唱音乐？因为她上大学时参加过合唱团之类的。那挺酷的。然后她拥有的仅有的两种流行唱片或非古典唱片是《Blood on the Tracks》（血迹斑斑）。太棒了。还有动物乐队的《House of the Rising Sun》（日落大道上的房子）。哇。哦，哇。
And so I played them to death.
And then we leaned heavily into the greatest hits by Bruce Springsteen.
That was like the family car record.
So that explains that you don't have an aversion or rather you have an attraction to
or an ability to incorporate these other instruments and instrumentation around your music.
Some people call it folk.
I know that that's not really accurate.
But the fact that you can work in all these different sense.
所以我把它们听了无数遍。然后我们大量倾听布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀的精选集。那就像是家庭汽车上的常备唱片。这说明你对音乐没有排斥感，或者说你有一种吸引力，能够将这些不同的乐器和编曲融入你的音乐中。有些人称之为民谣。我知道这其实并不准确。但你能把所有这些不同的感官元素融入其中
sounds and your music, your sound, the band's sound, is so full and varied.
Agreed.
Does that have some roots in the classical music that you were all the multiple instruments?
Yeah, maybe.
I think that's partly a reflection of the taste that, you know, amongst the band members.
Like me and Ben and Ted all have real different tastes in music, and it covers most genres.
Ben, like Ted's the best guitar, he's the bass player, he's the best guitarist in the band by a long way.
He plays jazz and blues and kind of studied it.
你的音乐，你的声音，乐队的声音，是如此饱满和多样化。同意。这是否植根于古典音乐，也就是你们接触过的多种乐器？对，也许吧。我认为这在一定程度上反映了乐队成员之间的品味。比如我和本和特德对音乐的品味有很大不同，涵盖了大多数流派。本，就像特德是最好的吉他——他是贝斯手，他是乐队里吉他弹得最好的人，远远超出其他人。他弹爵士乐和蓝调，并且专门研究过，
but plays the bass in the band
which is very kind of kind
actually and then Ben grew up
playing lots of classical and jazz on piano
and saxophone he was a better drummer than me at school
and then
I you know yeah we cover
most of the genres together
但在乐队里弹贝斯，这其实非常……而且本在学校里弹了很多古典和爵士钢琴以及萨克斯风。他在学校时是个比我更好的鼓手。然后我，你知道，对，我们一起涵盖了大多数流派。
and I think we've always felt like
whatever instruments suit the song that we're writing
at the time right you know
so we leaned heavily into like electric guitars
and stuff on the third and fourth records
and now I've kind of come back more
to the acoustic stuff and it's just fun
man. We love it.
而且我们一直觉得，不管什么乐器适合我们当时正在写的歌，对吧，你知道的，所以在第三张和第四张专辑中，我们大量使用了电吉他之类的乐器，现在我有点回到了原声乐器，这很有趣，老兄。我们爱死它了。
We'll be right back.
And now back to the show.
What about you playing so many different instruments?
That's not super common, right?
Well, the key is learning three chords on lots of instruments.
Yeah, but I mean, playing drums is so not the same as playing a guitar.
What's more difficult?
It seems like the drums would be very difficult to master, or is it just...
我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。你演奏这么多不同的乐器呢？这不是很常见，对吧？嗯，关键是在很多乐器上都学会三个和弦。对，但我的意思是，打鼓和弹吉他完全不一样。哪个更难？看起来打鼓要精通非常难，还是说只是……
Well, I mean, that was my instrument at school, and I took it for.
fairly seriously and did the grading system.
And that started with pots and pans in the kitchen,
my mom and dad.
And then I played all the way through high school.
I played at college just for the year that I lasted at college.
And then got hired as a drummer in a band.
So I quit college.
好吧，我的意思是，那是我在学校时的乐器，我相当认真地对待它，并通过了等级考试。这始于我爸爸妈妈在厨房里的锅碗瓢盆。然后我整个高中都在打鼓。我在大学里打了一年——也就是我唯一坚持了一年的大学生活。然后作为鼓手被雇用到一个乐队里。所以我退学了。
For Laura Marling, yeah.
So I quit college, go play for Laura.
Well done.
And that was my first job in music.
And that's really nice.
And so I got hired as a session drummer,
and I still like to play drums for people when I get the chance, honestly,
because I love it.
为了劳拉·马林，对。所以我退学去为劳拉演奏。干得好。那是我的第一份音乐工作。这真的很棒。所以我被雇为录音室鼓手，老实说，有机会时我仍然喜欢为别人打鼓，因为我太爱了。
And then I learned open tunings on the guitar
so that I could play it like a percussion instrument, really,
without having to read...
I can read drum music.
I can't read, you know, other music.
Oh, really?
Does drum music look like?
Yeah.
然后我在吉他上学会了开放式调弦，这样我就可以像打击乐器一样弹奏它，而不需要去读……我能看懂鼓谱。我看不懂，你知道的，其他乐谱。哦，真的吗？鼓谱长什么样？对。
It's still on a stave.
Yeah, there's X's and there's Nauts and Crosses, basically.
And so, like, the snare is an X,
and the kick drum is a...
Yeah, the kick...
The bass drum goes at the bottom,
and then the snare is like two down,
you know, where the C would normally be.
它依然是在五线谱上。对，有叉号，基本上是叉和圈。所以，比如军鼓是一个叉，底鼓是一个……对，底鼓。底鼓在最下面，然后军鼓大概往下两格，你知道的，通常是C音的位置。
And the hi-hats are on top,
and they're normally X's,
and then the symbols are on top of that.
They stack it on the way.
So, you know, the note?
Like, there's a line...
Yeah.
And the black dot.
镲片在最上面，通常是叉号，然后铜镲在它们上面。它们是这样堆叠的。所以，你知道音符吗？就像有一条线……对。还有一个黑点。
Yeah.
Instead, it's a line with an X, and that's percussion.
For symbols, it's an X.
Yeah.
Huh.
Wait, Jason and Will, did you guys ever...
Did you ever...
对。取而代之的是一条带叉的线，那就是打击乐器。对于镲片，它就是一个叉。对。哈。哈。等等，杰森和威尔，你们俩……你们曾经……
Try to learn an instrument or no?
Piano, I played as a little kid,
and then when I got too big to be pushed around,
I said, I'm out.
Yeah, sure, I understand that.
So you always had a great attitude.
Is that what you're saying?
You're consistent.
尝试过学乐器吗？没有？钢琴，我小时候弹过，然后当我长得太大而不能被推来推去时，我说，我不干了。对，当然，我理解这一点。所以你一直都有个好态度。你是这个意思吗？你很一致。
No, it was, it wasn't, it wasn't like.
I wish I had.
I wish I'd stayed with him.
But, you know, it's like, my parents, like they said,
you know, like it's a form of discipline.
You're going to have to do your practice for an hour.
every single day.
Yeah, yeah.
不，这，这不是，这不是那种……我希望我坚持下来了。我希望我坚持学了。但是，你知道的，这就像，我父母，他们说，你知道的，这是一种纪律形式。你每天都得练习一个小时。对，对。
So they made it fun.
Exactly.
Like that was a problem.
Like, you know, they should have made it fun.
Like any kid, you're going to try to cheat and not practice.
And so they set up a tape recorder that I had to put on the piano and press record during my one hour practice to prove that I was practicing.
Of course, it was the same music that I was practicing each and every week.
So you just record it once and just turn that in.
所以他们把它弄得很有趣。没错。好像那是个问题。就像，你知道的，任何小孩子都会试图偷懒不练习。所以他们设置了一个录音机，我必须把它放在钢琴上，在我一小时的练习期间按下录音键来证明我在练习。当然，每周我练习的都是同一首音乐。所以你只要录一次，然后把那个交上去。
Record it once.
And they bought it.
You know, you're not getting any better by Friday each week.
Yeah.
That was your audition for It's Your Move.
That sounds like the thing
of your character
and It's Your Move would have done.
录一次。他们还真信了。你知道的，到每周五你的水平也没有任何提高。对。那是你为《是你迈出这一步》进行的试镜。听起来就像你在《是你迈出这一步》里扮演的角色会做的事情。
The show Jason did when he was like 15.
It was so funny, Marcus,
I played over here.
It was a brilliant show
where he just played a kid
who did shit like that all the time.
I wish, yeah, I wish I had,
I did a couple instruments here and there
杰森15岁时拍的那部剧。太搞笑了，马库斯，我在那边演的。那是一部精彩的剧，他扮演一个总做这种混蛋事的孩子。我希望，对，我希望我有，我上学时断断续续学了几个乐器，我希望，我只是希望我能坚持下来。这是那种，比如我希望我能，我能在吉他上非常笨拙地弹四个和弦。我只是……
during school and I wish,
I just wish I'd stuck with it.
It's one of those, like I wish I'd,
I can play four chords on a guitar really sloppily.
I just...
But let me ask you this, Marcus,
to that, to Will's point is like,
once you learn and become proficient as you have in so many areas of music
但让我问你这个，马库斯，针对威尔的观点，一旦你学会并精通了音乐的许多领域，正如你所做的那样，
and not only music singing and all that,
is you don't listen to other music the same way.
Yeah, that's true.
Whereas somebody like Will or Jay who...
I love music.
Yeah, you have a different appreciation for it,
not that you don't if you know it, but, you know, it's just a different ear.
We had this conversation the other day we had a party at home.
不仅是音乐、唱歌和所有这些，你听其他音乐的方式就不一样了。对，那是真的。而像威尔或杰伊这样的人……我喜欢音乐。对，你们对它有不同的欣赏，并不是说如果你懂的话就没有，但是，你知道的，这只是一种不同的耳朵。我们前几天在家里办派对时聊过这个。
It was Carrie's birthday.
And someone came and they were like, there's no music.
And I was like, yeah, we don't really play music.
I can't do background music.
As if music's on, I want to lean in and listen to it.
And I can't switch that part of my brain off.
So then Kerry doesn't like having music in the house
because I just stop having a conversation.
那是凯瑞的生日。有人来的时候说，没有音乐。我说，对，我们其实不怎么放音乐。我无法忍受背景音乐。如果音乐放着，我想深入进去听。我无法关掉我大脑的那一部分。所以凯瑞不喜欢家里放音乐，因为我一听音乐就不说话了。
Like if music comes on, I just...
And she'll be like, you've gone.
I was like, oh, sorry, let's turn it off then, I guess.
And then when you listen to it, do you,
do you analyze it, the chord progressions, the melodies?
Yeah, yeah, normally, you know,
and a lot of the time, then sort of store it to try and copy it, you know.
Yeah, sure, sure.
比如音乐一响，我就……然后她会说，“你神游了”。我就说，“哦，抱歉，那我们关掉它吧”。然后当你听音乐时，你会不会去分析它，分析和弦进行、旋律？对，对，通常会，你知道的，很多时候，然后把它储存在脑子里试着去模仿它，你知道的。对，当然，当然。
Do you listen to a lot of new music at all?
Yeah, yeah, I listen to probably mostly new music, actually,
and if I'm on my own, that's when I listen to music.
And how are you finding the new stuff?
Is somebody giving you tips on like, oh, you should check this out?
Or how about this, you know, all those streaming services, they like, they figure out what you like and then they send you suggestions and stuff.
Do you find that helpful? Do you follow some of those?
Sometimes, some of my favorite music I've found on TikTok when I was on it.
你平时听很多新音乐吗？对，对，我听的可能大多是新音乐，实际上，如果我独自一人，那就是我听音乐的时候。你是怎么发现那些新东西的？有人给你提供建议吗，比如“嘿，你应该听听这个”？或者像这样，你知道的，所有那些流媒体服务，它们会找出你喜欢什么，然后给你发送建议之类的。你觉得这有帮助吗？你会关注其中一些吗？有时会，我最喜欢的一些音乐是我在玩TikTok时在上面发现的。
And now I'm not on it.
My new music has dried up a bit, actually.
I was enjoying that.
There's an amazing British band called Divorce, a great band name, who became my new favorite obsession.
I was completely obsessed with them,
and we got them to come on tour with us,
which was fun.
But I just found the algorithm, you know, fed them to me.
现在我不用了。我的新音乐来源确实有点枯竭了。我以前挺享受那个的。有一个很棒的英国乐队叫Divorce，乐队名字很棒，成了我新的最爱。我完全迷上了他们，我们还邀请他们和我们一起巡演，这很有趣。但我发现算法，你知道的，把他们喂给了我。
So you found them and said,
hey, let's get these guys come on tour with us.
Yeah, and then we ended up recording a song together.
Oh, that's great.
I love that.
Wait, you had to cut yourself off from TikTok?
Is that when I'm sniffing out?
I did, yeah.
所以你发现了他们，然后说，“嘿，让这些家伙和我们一起巡演吧”？对，然后我们最后一起录了一首歌。哦，太棒了。我太喜欢了。等等，你不得不克制自己不玩TikTok？这是我嗅到的意思吗？是的，我做了，
I just, well, I did it ahead of putting out the new record
because I just wanted to be insulated
from how other people felt about it,
because I knew how I felt about it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I didn't need some, like, comment somewhere, spoiling my experience
because I was happy with it.
Good for you.
我只是，嗯，我在推出新专辑之前这样做了，因为我只想免受其他人对它的看法的影响，因为我知道我对它的感受。对，对，对。我不需要某个地方的评论破坏我的体验，因为我对它很满意。为你高兴。
And I couldn't change it.
It was done.
And this is the first time I've ever put a record out where I genuinely have not read a word about it.
And I feel free.
I love that.
That's cool.
It's cool.
I mean, it's a privilege, obviously, but it's cool.
而且我无法改变它。它已经完成了。这是我第一次发行一张专辑，我真的一个字都没有读关于它的评论。我感到自由。我喜欢这样。太酷了。这很酷。我的意思是，这显然是一种特权，但它很酷。
So other people do our socials and stuff.
And, you know, we send stuff over and we think about it.
We're intentional about it.
But I don't have to do any of it or be on any of it, which is cool.
You must come across, you must come across bands and stuff.
when you're touring too, or if you do a festival,
do you, like, all of a sudden, do you find yourself going,
oh, wait, what is that going on over there
所以其他人负责我们的社交媒体之类的。而且，你知道的，我们把东西发过去，我们思考它。我们对此是有意图的。但我不需要做任何这些，也不需要在上面泡着，这很酷。你一定遇到过，你一定遇到过各种乐队，
and, like, and hear somebody that way?
Does that ever happen?
Yeah, yeah, and a lot of the time, it's just recommendations from mates, you know.
They're like, you should listen to this.
And sometimes when we're discussing who to come on the road,
one of us will pipe up with something we've been listening to,
you know, because we're very intentional about who comes out
and supports us on tour.
当你在巡演时，或者如果你去参加音乐节，你是不是，突然之间，你会发现自己在想，“哦，等等，那边在发生什么”？并且通过这种方式听到某个人？这种情况发生过吗？对，对，很多时候，这只是朋友的推荐，你知道的。他们会说：“你应该听听这个。”有时当我们在讨论谁来和我们一起巡演时，我们中的一个人会突然说出一些我们一直在听的音乐，你知道的，因为我们对谁来做我们的巡演嘉宾非常有针对性。
Because those are the shows I go to now.
Yeah, right, mostly.
And I'll go, and every night I don't like,
playing a show without watching the support band
first because it just gets me in the mood and it
makes me feel what the room's like. Yeah, of course.
Yeah. There's a new English band
that I've been obsessed with, West Side Cowboy.
因为那是我现在去看的演出。对，没错，大多如此。我会去，而且每天晚上我不会……不看暖场乐队的演出就直接上台，因为这能让我进入状态，让我感受到现场的氛围。对，当然。对。有一个我一直很迷恋的新英国乐队，West Side Cowboy。
Have you heard these guys? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So fucking good, man.
Didn't they support Geese on their
run? Oh, did they? I think they support.
Yeah, them and Dav Ellis. So that
I found Dav Ellis through Geese
because I knew he was on the road with
them. And I'm
你听说过这些人吗？对，对，对。他妈的太棒了，老兄。他们不是在Geese的巡演中做暖场吗？哦，是吗？我想他们是。对，他们和达夫·埃利斯。所以我通过Geese发现了达夫·埃利斯，因为我知道他和他们一起在路上。然后我
like, you know, the rest of the internet
obsessed with them. And
And yeah, that's how I found Davellis.
So a lot of the time it's just like, who's playing with who
and these little communities that pop up,
which we were part of when we first started as a band.
And that's really how people discovered us
because they'd come to a Laura Marley.
就像，你知道的，互联网的其他部分都迷上了他们。然后，是的，这就是我发现达夫·埃利斯的方式。所以很多时候这只是，谁和谁一起演出以及这些涌现的小社团，我们在作为乐队刚开始时就是其中的一部分。这真的是人们发现我们的方式，因为他们会去劳拉·马林的演出。
That's how Carrie found out about it.
She booked a ticket to a Laura Marling show.
And then we started shouting sort of an hour before Laura went on.
And then she was like, oh, Mumford, I knew a kid called Mumford.
And that's so I love those little communities still, you know.
Yeah, yeah.
She left a note with our tour manager.
She didn't come backstage.
凯瑞就是这样发现的。她订了一张劳拉·马林演出的票。然后我们在劳拉上台前大约一个小时开始大喊大叫。然后她就想，“哦，芒福德，我认识一个叫芒福德的孩子。”所以我依然很喜欢那些小社团，你知道的。对，对。她给我们巡演经理留了张便条。她没有去后台。
No, she left a note.
See, that's classic.
That's really classy.
Wait, so I'm embarrassed.
She probably told us this, I apologize for forgetting.
So on the note, did she say,
hey, so I did know this guy named Mumford.
I forget his first name.
不，她留了便条。你看，这太经典了。这真的很酷。等等，那我挺尴尬的。她可能跟我们说过这事，我忘了，真抱歉。所以在便条上，她是不是说，嘿，其实我认识一个叫芒福德的人。我忘了他的名是什么。
Is his name?
No, do you know what?
We were both, I guess, on Facebook for like a six-month window
when I was still at college,
and we connected there.
And then this was like a couple years after that
when we'd started the band.
and I was still playing in Laura's band.
他叫什么？不，你知道吗？我猜我们俩都在Facebook上待过大约六个月，当时我还在上大学，我们在那儿联系上了。然后这是几年之后的事了，当时我们刚组建乐队，而我还在劳拉的乐队里弹琴。
And so she left a note with our tour manager
with her email address on it, I think.
Wow.
So knowing that it was you, once she saw you on stage, maybe?
Yeah, yeah.
It's great.
You know what's great about this, Marcus, but also email,
not the phone number.
所以我想，她给我们的巡演经理留了一张便条，上面写着她的电子邮件地址。哇。所以一旦她在舞台上看到你，就知道那是你了，也许吧？对，对。这太棒了。你知道这最棒的地方是什么吗，马库斯，还有邮箱，不是电话号码。
Just another layer.
You know what I mean?
Slow play, real classy.
She's a classy broad.
A classy broad.
When did you know that music might actually be
a path towards a living for you
又多了一层。你知道我的意思吗？打法保守，真有品位。她是个有品位的时髦女子。她是个有品位的时髦女子。一个有品位的时髦女子。你是什么时候意识到音乐可能真的会成为你谋生的途径的呢
as opposed to just fun.
Still not convinced.
Still in some state of arrested development.
What a base.
Now that was a band.
For Sean, that's a TV show that was on.
I gotta write that show.
For Sean.
而不是仅仅为了好玩。我还是不确定。依然处于某种发育停滞的状态。多么棒的贝斯。那才叫乐队。对肖恩来说，那是一部曾经播出的电视剧。我得写那个节目。致肖恩。
I think...
Is it playing now?
Was also a good band.
I think it's like...
I was at college.
I got offered a job playing music.
I wasn't having a great time at college,
so I stopped.
我想……现在还在播吗？以前也是个好乐队。我觉得就像是……我在上大学时。我得到了一份演奏音乐的工作。我在大学过得并不太开心，所以我停下来了。
and took a sabbatical.
Where'd you go to college?
And I think Edinburgh.
And I think in my head I'm still on my...
Until quite recently, I've been on my sabbatical from college.
Sure, sure.
I mean thinking that you would probably go back?
Yeah.
去休了个学术假。你以前在哪儿上大学？我想是在爱丁堡。我想在我的脑海里，我还在……直到不久前，我一直都在休大学的学术假。当然，当然。我是说你当时觉得你可能会回去？对。
And what would you have studied if you'd gone back?
I was doing classics.
I was doing Greek and Latin.
What, literature?
To do what?
Unclear.
You know, it's not a vocational...
No, it isn't.
如果你回去了，你会学什么专业？我当时学的是古典学。我学的是希腊语和拉丁语。什么，文学？去干什么？不清楚。你知道，这不是个职业导向的……不，确实不是。
Just reading?
Reading?
It's what a lot of lawyers.
To be a monk?
Yeah.
Classics in the UK particularly
is seen as like a good, honest,
old school degree to do
就只是阅读？阅读？这正是许多律师会做的事。去当修道士？ yeah。古典学在英国尤其被视为一个好、诚实、老派的学位
if you're doing something.
But what do you do with that?
I don't understand.
He said lawyers, yeah?
Oh, lawyer.
Well, what's cool about it as a...
Come a member of parliament.
Yeah, a lot of those.
如果你要做点什么的话。但你用它能做什么？我不明白。他刚才说律师，对吧？哦，律师。好吧，它厉害的地方在于——成为一名国会议员。对，很多这种人。
A lot of prime ministers do it.
But I wasn't on that track.
What's cool about it is
it gives you access to poetry
and philosophy and storytelling and language and linguistics,
anthropology, ancient history,
all these things that you study through the original languages.
Jason, you're drooling.
很多首相都是学这个的。但我当时可没走那条路。它厉害的地方在于，它能让你接触到诗歌、哲学、讲故事、语言与语言学、人类学、古代历史，所有这些通过原语言学习的事物。杰森，你在流口水。
Your mouth is up on your drool.
So it's really geeky, and you get your geek goggles out when you're talking about.
I bet it helps you when you write lyrics.
And it's how I got introduced to poetry.
It's how I fell in love with words, honestly.
And then I started reading T.S. Eliot really pretentiously as like a 17-year-old
And suddenly words had a new depth to them.
And, you know, he was a classicist too.
你的口水都快挂到嘴边了。所以这真的很书呆子气，你一聊起这个就会戴上你的书呆子眼镜。我敢打赌这能帮到你写歌词。说实话，这就是我接触诗歌的方式。这也是我爱上文字的方式。然后我开始像个17岁的文艺青年一样，非常装模作样地读T.S. 艾略特，突然之间，文字有了新的深度。而且，你知道的，他也是个古典学者。
And the references, a lot of classical references,
and I'd sort of read a bit of Homer and then switch over to Elliot
and be like, oh, cool, look at the way he's joined up
and referred back to this.
Can't you just see 17-year-old Marx just riding a bicycle
through some field and then just like dropping into a field
and reading poetry?
Yeah, with a bad cat and a basket on the bike.
还有那些典故，有很多古典典故，我大概读了一点荷马史诗，然后转去读艾略特，就会觉得，哦，太酷了，你看他是怎么把这些串联起来并回溯过去的。难道你想象不到17岁的马库斯骑着自行车穿过某片田野，然后一头扎进田野里读诗的样子吗？对，自行车篮里还装着一只坏脾气的猫。
I was that guy. I was sat on the train to Edinburgh
I wore a thick fabric and a collar that I cut the collar off my shirt
because I'd seen the assassination of Jesse James
and just got deep into poetry.
And honestly, until this last record,
I've been in denial about that too.
You know, I've been in this process of being like,
this is kind of who I am now, this is what I do.
我就是那种人。我坐在去爱丁堡的火车上，穿着厚厚的面料，衬衫领子都被我剪掉了，因为我刚看过《刺杀杰西·詹姆斯》，然后就深深地迷上了诗歌。老实说，直到这张新专辑之前，我对这一点也一直都在否认。你知道的，我一直在经历这样一个过程，觉得：这差不多就是现在的我，这就是我做的事。
So for Prize Fighter, I'd go and sit in the coffee shops
in Hudson, New York,
because we were recording with Aaron Destin at Longpond,
and I'd sit in the coffee shop for two hours every morning,
and I'd do my artist's way, like, morning pages,
and I'd sit and read poetry like a real twat
and just really lent in to, I guess, my identity at this point,
and it helped me write lyrics, you know.
所以在做《奖金猎人》（Prize Fighter）这张专辑时，我会去纽约州哈德逊的咖啡馆坐坐，因为我们当时在长塘（Long Pond）和阿伦·德斯纳（Aaron Dessner）一起录音，我每天早上会在咖啡馆坐上两个小时，写我的“艺术家之路”晨间随笔，然后坐在那里像个真正的白痴一样读诗，真正地融入到我现在的身份中去，这确实帮我写出了歌词。
Let's hit Babel for a second here.
So what did the incredible success of that album do for you?
personally, like, was it jarring to sort of have that next step of success and recognition and treasure?
And like, was it, did you adapt well to that?
Was it, was it a fun thing or was it a bit disruptive?
That's a great question, actually.
Thank you.
Finally for once.
咱们花点时间聊聊《巴别塔》（Babel）这张专辑吧。那么，这张专辑取得的不可思议的成功给你带来了什么？从个人角度来说，比如说，当成功、认可和财富迈上下一步时，那种感觉会不会让人感到突兀和冲击？还有就是，你对那种情况适应得好吗？这是一件有趣的事，还是有点具有颠覆性？这其实是个好问题。谢谢。终于有一次了。
I don't think anyone, unless you may be one of Simon Cowell's projects, I don't think you're trained.
you know, to have that kind of level of success.
We started playing music because we loved playing.
We loved each other.
And it was just fun.
And we got free beers.
And then suddenly, we were playing 250 shows a year.
And then suddenly, you know, the first record starts gaining some pace.
我想没有人——除非你可能是西蒙·考威尔（Simon Cowell）的项目之一——我想你根本没有接受过训练，去承受那种级别的成功。我们开始玩音乐是因为我们热爱演奏。我们深爱彼此。这纯粹只是好玩。我们能喝到免费啤酒。然后突然之间，我们一年要演250场。然后突然之间，你知道的，第一张专辑开始有了起色。
We took six weeks off tour to make Babel,
which our producer at the time was really frustrated about.
He's like, why do you have shows booked on the other side of a recording process
that's really dumb,
creatively but we rushed it
and I think we got it right but it
was pressurized and then
the success of that
我们请了六周的巡演假来制作《巴别塔》，当时的制作人对此非常沮丧。他觉得：为什么你们在录音流程的另一头还排满了演出？这从创意角度来看太蠢了。但我们赶工了，我觉得我们做对了，不过压力确实很大。然后那张专辑
record around the world really
and particularly in the States
just opened us up to a world
we weren't like ever anticipating
or planning for
and
yeah
I mean I don't think unless
在全世界，尤其是在美国取得的成功，真正把我们带入了一个我们从未预料到或规划过的世界。是的，我的意思是我不认为除了
you're a kind of pop project
you're even imagining
it and then suddenly
the shows are all selling out
and you're moving into bigger spaces
and fulfilling lots of your dreams as a kid
like to headline Glastonbury
we only did on two records
你是个流行音乐项目，否则你根本连想都不会想到这一点。然后突然之间，门票全卖光了，你们开始去更大的场地演出，实现了许多儿时的梦想，比如在格拉斯顿伯里音乐节压轴演出，而我们只出了两张专辑就做到了。
I remember getting at the end of the set
we basically had to play the whole of both records
to fill the time
and I remember getting the end of the set
and just being like, we just need more songs man
that's all we got
we need more songs because you watch
Springsteen play for three hours and he's playing like
我记得在演出快结束时，我们基本上得把两张专辑的所有歌都唱完才能凑够时长。我记得演出结束时，我就觉得：我们得有更多的歌啊，老兄，这就是我们全部的存货了，我们需要更多的歌。因为你看斯普林斯汀（Springsteen）能连演三个小时，而且全都是金曲连发、首首炸裂。对，对。所以，是的，我真的没有为那张专辑的成功做好准备。我觉得我们对它的反应有点过度了，我们在第三张专辑里制作了一张没人对我们抱有期望的专辑。没人特别想要它，但我们自己很爱它。它也把我们带进了更大的演出场所。这就是它走向宏大的过程。
just hit after hit after hit
yeah yeah
so yeah I
I wasn't really prepared for the success of that record.
And I think we reacted to it a bit by making a record on the third one that no one was expecting from us.
No one particularly wanted, but we loved it.
And it took us into bigger rooms as well.
And that was how it went widescreen.
然后是第四张专辑。接着在第五和第六张专辑之间，我们隔了很长一段时间。是的。那段时间有多长？纸面上看是七年。我的意思是，其中有两年我们是在《三角洲》（Delta）发行后一直在巡演，然后新冠疫情就爆发了。是的。
And then the fourth record.
And then we had a long gap before the fifth and sixth records.
Yeah.
How long was that gap?
That was like on paper.
It was seven years.
I mean, we were touring for two of those after Delta came out and then COVID happened.
Yeah.
所以作为乐队，我们大概分开了三年吧，是的。当第一波巨大成功袭来时，最大的适应过程是什么？我的意思是，最显而易见的当然是更多的观众和门票售罄，可能会住上更好的酒店，坐飞机而不是坐巡演大巴从一个城市到另一个城市，或者只是诸如此类无聊的事情。但那一定也很让人头晕目眩吧？你看着人们，你知道的，成群结队地合唱你们的歌，可能还会收到一些关于你们如何影响人们、在一定程度上改变他们生活的反馈。
So we were a part as a band for maybe three years, yeah.
That's what was that biggest adjustment there when that first wave of big success came in?
I mean, obviously most notable would be the bigger crowds and the sellouts
and it would probably be nicer hotels and you're flying from city to city instead of the buses maybe
or just silly things like that.
But it must have been pretty heady too, right?
You're watching people, you know, sing your songs en masse.
and probably getting some feedback as to how you're affecting people and changing their lives a bit.
而且，你知道的，可能一个比较软弱、更缺乏安全感的人会非常相信这些，把大部分功劳归于自己。我敢打赌你多少会抵消掉一些这种情绪，尽量让一切都围绕着音乐，保持简单。但你来告诉我。它确实助长了我内心原本就存在的一点羞耻叙事，我对此进行过一些反思。我当时喝的酒可能比我应该喝的要多一点。就像是冒名顶替综合征那种感觉？对，有点那种感觉。是的，绝对有那种感觉。而且我有点封闭自己。
And, you know, probably a weaker, more insecure person would probably buy into that a lot and kind of own a lot of that.
I'll bet you sort of deflected a bit of that and tried to keep it all about the music and keep it simple.
But you tell me.
It drove a bit of my shame narrative that was already there that I've looked,
at a little bit. I drank a bit more than probably I should have.
Like imposter kind of stuff?
Yeah, a bit of that. Yeah, a bit of that for sure.
And I went in a bit.
在舞台上，你会表现得非常外放，你知道的，毫无保留地奉献自己。然后我的朋友圈子缩小了一些。是的，我想，是的，我的确借酒浇愁，尤其是把它当作一种逃避的方式。然后贯穿这一切的实话实说，我的婚姻绝对是一切当中最美好的部分。是的，是的。所以我觉得随着我们年龄的增长，这一切都会自然而然地发生，而且以一种非常健康的方式。我觉得大多数人的那个圈子都会变小，你会更准确地弄清楚你是谁，什么才是真正适合你的。这通常等同于一种更小、更具体、
And on stage, you'd be very out, you know, give yourself completely.
And then my friendship circle shrunk a bit.
Yeah.
I think, yeah, I did use booze, particularly as a bit of an escape.
and then really throughout it all honestly my marriage has just been the best thing about everything
yeah yeah so but i think as we get older it all it's sort of naturally and in a very healthy way i
think most people that circle gets smaller you figure out more accurately who you are and what the
what the what the proper fits are for you and that usually equates to a smaller more specific
更精准的人际体验。对吧？你不会再去到处“购物”寻找……是的，而且我认为我开始认识到“承载力”这个概念。是的。因为特别是那几年的时间里，我的精力分散得太厉害了。我的意思是，你们做这份工作一定也有同感。
more precise experience with people.
Right?
You're not out there shopping as much for...
Yeah, and I think I recognize the idea of capacity.
Yeah.
Because for a few years there particularly,
I was spread really thin.
I mean, you guys must find this with your jobs as well.
你遇到了太多人，其中很多人你都很喜欢，然后你想和他们交朋友，接着你又跟其他人建立联系，然后我发现自己的精力分散得太厉害，根本没有做朋友的好榜样。对吧。然后那种圈子缩小的过程就发生了。
You meet so many people,
and a lot of them you love,
and then you want to be friends with,
and then you connect with other people,
and then I found myself getting spread really thinly
and not being very good friends to my friends.
Right.
and then that shrinking happened a bit.
所以是以一种健康的、我猜是这样的方式。所以我想，是的，我觉得你说得对。部分原因确实是人在长大。但我也承认，我确实用了一些不太健康的方式来应对这一切。后来我戒酒了，与其说是出于必要，不如说是出于选择，尽管，你知道的，我们也可以探讨这一点。然后我用冰激凌代替了酒，持续了一段时间，直到有人告诉我，你知道的，我一点体重都没减。
So in a kind of healthy way, I think.
So I guess it's, yeah, I think you're right.
It's partly growing up.
But yeah, I suppose I dealt with it all in a bit of unhealthy ways.
Then I stopped drinking booze more out of choice than necessity,
although, you know, we could debate that.
And then replaced it with ice cream for a while
until I was told, you know, I wasn't losing any weight.
我对这整整一天感到非常困惑。我们在那条路上有相似的经历，我也走过那条路，戒酒之后就进入了以冰激凌为主的饮食阶段，对，对，因为你会想念糖分。
It was really confused about the whole day.
We have similar paths in that way
I did that route too
where it was like an ice cream-based diet
after I quit booze
Yeah
Because you miss the sugar
我还记得那段经历，是的。我也很想念它。等等，马库斯，你知道我总是挺感兴趣的，大概过去了一个小时，至少我开始有点发抖了，你知道我一直对一件事很好奇
I remember that
Yeah I miss it too
Wait Marcus
You know I'm always kind of interested
Probably been an hour
At least
I'm like starting to shake
You know I'm always interested
当像你这样拥有乐队的人告诉我——你接受过声乐训练吗，或者懂不懂任何技巧，或者怎么用嗓子？因为当我去听，比如说，我是个狂热的流行尖端（Depeche Mode）粉丝。他们也上过这个播客。真的太疯狂了。我也是你的超级粉丝，我也喜欢各种各样的音乐。
When people like you
who have bands and you tell me,
did you have vocal training or know any,
or how to use your voice or because when I go,
for example, I'm a massive Depeche Mode fan.
They came out on the podcast.
It was really wild.
I'm also a huge fan of yours and I love all kinds of music too.
然后我去听大卫·加汉（Dave Gahan）唱歌，我一眼就能看出：哦，他没有热身。然后在前两首歌之后，他的嗓子才稍微打开了一点，接着就很棒了。从一开始其实就很棒，但随着《享受信仰》（Reach Out and Touch Faith）这首歌不断深入……那么，你有没有接受过任何形式的训练？或者当你在巡演时有没有意识到：哦操，我根本不知道该怎么照顾我这种爆发力极强的嗓音？对，我曾坚信威士忌和香烟真的很有帮助，没错。然后就在最近，
And I went to go see Dave Gahan sing and I can tell right away,
oh, he didn't warm up.
And then after the first couple songs,
his voice kind of opened up a little bit and then it was great.
great and it was great from the beginning too but just kept reach out and touch faith
and then do you do did you have any kind of training or did you realize when you were touring like
oh shit i don't know how to take care of the kind of athleticism of my voice yeah i i was convinced
for years that whiskey and cigarettes really helped yeah right and then just recently i've
布兰迪·卡莱尔（Brandi Carlile）把我介绍给了她的声乐教练，一个叫罗布·史蒂文森（Rob Stevenson）的家伙，他彻底改变了我的世界，并给我普及了一些知识。比如说，嗓音是一块肌肉，你必须给它热身。我很幸运，没有……我看着身边的朋友们
started actually brandy carl introduced me to her
vocal coach, guy called Rob Stevenson,
who's totally changed
my world and giving me some education
on stuff.
Like, it's a muscle and you have to warm it up.
And I've been lucky
not to, and I watched friends around me get
被声带息肉的问题困扰，失去了嗓子。我们从来没有——我觉得我们过去从来没有因为我的嗓音问题而取消过演出。这真的很酷。就像我记得取消过的仅有的几场演出，是因为特德（Ted）脑溢血了。哦，天哪。
affected by the Palleps thing and losing their voices.
We've never, I don't think
we've cancelled a show for my voice
in the past. Which has been
cool. Like the only couple of shows that I remember
cancelling were because Ted had a
had a brain hemorrhage.
Oh, jeez.
这其实一点也不好笑。振作起来。但现在回想起来挺搞笑的，因为他有一段时间不得不戴着帽子。但他做完那个手术两周后就在格拉斯顿伯里音乐节压轴登场了，简直像个传奇。我想我们为此只取消了两场演出。总之我们一直挺幸运的，我的嗓子也很抗造。太惊人了。但我最近意识到它确实是一块肌肉。
Which wasn't funny at all.
Get up.
But now is quite funny because he had to wear a hat for a while.
But he headlined Glastonbury two weeks after getting that surgery, like a legend.
And I think we cancelled two shows for that.
But we've just been lucky and my voice has been resilient.
Amazing.
But I think recently I've realised it's a muscle.
现在我开始了，现在我有一套完整的日常流程来保养它。我戒烟了，还有诸如此类的事。哦，很好，很好，很好。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。关于声带息肉，那是什么意思？因为我切除过声带息肉，难道这意味着你心理上很脆弱？
Now I start, and now I have a full routine and I look after it.
I quit smoking and all that stuff.
Oh, good, good, good.
And we will be right back.
And back to the show.
What does that mean about the polyps?
Because I had polyps removed from my vocal cords,
but it means you're weak psychologically.
哦，该死。没错，这就是钢琴课的梗。因为它就像钢琴，你父母是对的。这纯粹是为了磨练性格。 yeah，太遗憾了。不，不过医生确实说过我使用嗓子的方式不对，因为我当时总是在酒吧里大喊大叫，
Oh, damn it.
Yeah, it's the piano lesson thing.
It's because it's a piano,
your parents were right.
It was character development.
Yeah, what a shame.
No, but I think the doctor did say that I wasn't using my voice correctly
because I was like screaming in bars.
还抽烟什么的。他说我就是这样把嗓子给毁了。那些不知道怎么正确热身的音乐人或歌手都会这样吗？你的声带上会长出息肉？老实说我不太清楚。我觉得日积月累的磨损确实是这样的。是的。
and smoking cigarettes and stuff.
And he said, I just, I wrecked it that way.
Is that what happens to musicians or to singers
that don't know how to warm up correctly?
You can create polyps on your vocal cords?
I honestly don't know.
I think the wear and tear of it, is it, is true.
Yeah.
我知道，比如演出结束之后，我再也不去那种地方了，因为演出结束后在嘈杂的房间里说话是对嗓子伤害最大的事。没错。所以在演出结束后，我会进入让嗓子休息的状态。我倒也不是对它过度小心翼翼，没错。
I know that, like, going out after show,
I just don't ever do that anymore
because talking in loud rooms after shows
is the thing that is worse for your voice.
Right.
So after a show, I don't go on voice rest.
I'm not like precious about it.
Right.
但我不会出门。我会远离喧闹的场所有。好吧，你还有一个你爱的妻子和三个需要你花时间陪伴的孩子，你知道的。而且，我也变得相当无聊和像个修道士一样了，你知道的。杰森，阿曼达得过声带息肉吗？哦，天哪。我在大喊大叫。
But I don't go out.
And I stay away from a loud place.
Well, you also have a wife you love and three kids
that you've got to go spend time with too, you know?
Also, I've just become quite boring and monkish, you know.
Jason, Amanda ever developed poplops?
Oh, boy.
I'm screaming.
那是你的约会对象。那是你的约会对象。我懂。我爱她。我爱她
That's your date.
I know.
I love her.
more than anything in the whole world.
Hey, so...
I lost my voice two days ago, actually, a little bit.
胜过世界上的一切。嘿，所以……其实我两天前刚失声过一小会儿。
Really?
Yeah.
Too bad you found it.
Wait, Will, have you ever checked out?
Go ahead.
Jay.
I lost mine two weeks ago.
Yeah, it's still weak.
真的吗？对。幸亏你又找到了。等等，威廉，你有没有去检查过……说吧，杰。我两周前刚失声过。是的，现在嗓子还是有点虚。
I still...
Like, if I ever did theater, I'd have a real...
I would need to take real lessons about how to use my house.
Have you not done theater?
No.
I mean, tiny, small room stuff.
But, like, if I ever did it, you know, here in New York,
I'd lead to help.
我还是觉得……如果我要去演戏剧的话，我会遇到很大的……我需要去上真正的声乐课，学习如何使用我的嗓音。你没演过戏剧吗？没有。我是说，那种极小的微型场地演出。但如果我真要演的话，你知道的，就在纽约这里，我会需要帮助的。
Jay, I was thinking the same thing.
Yesterday, I didn't fully lose it, but I was really close,
and I thought, I was just thinking about you, Sean,
and about how you've been basically on stage
for the last three years, kind of straight.
Yeah, and Marcus, you must have the same thing.
And I thought, I'm going through this thing of like,
I wouldn't, if I were in a play right now, I'd be fucked.
杰，我也有同感。昨天，我虽然没有彻底失声，但也差不多了，当时我就在想你，肖恩，想你过去这三年基本上一直在舞台上连轴转。是的，马库斯，你肯定也有这种感觉。当时我就在想，我在经历这种状况，如果我现在去演一出话剧，我绝对死定了。
I wouldn't be able to be able to do it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, you really have to take care of it.
And, Sean, do you do, like, a full hour every night before you?
Yeah, and there's songs that I'll sing to one.
Like if I know if I'll sing all by myself and if I can hit that high note.
Let's have it.
All by my...
Then I can do the whole show.
我根本应付不来。是的，是的，是的，是的，你真的必须好好保养它。肖恩，你每天晚上上台前都会做整整一个小时的热身吗？是的，而且有些歌我会对着它唱。就像我知道我会唱《全靠我自己》（All by Myself），如果我能唱出那个高音的话。来一个。全靠我自……那我就能撑完整场演出。
Sick.
You know what I mean?
It's funny. And you usually do it through tears, right?
Right.
No, that's the song because it was a one-man show, so I would sing all by myself.
Uh-huh.
Marcus, do you have a go-to little thing that you do for warm-up?
Like a little scale thing or something like that?
太牛了。你知道我的意思吗？这挺逗的。而且你通常都是含着泪唱完的，对吧？对。不，那首歌是因为这是一场独角戏，所以我才会唱《全靠我自己》。嗯哼。马库斯，你有什么每次热身时的拿手绝活吗？比如来个小音阶练习之类的？
Yeah, I do.
It's called The Penguin Noise.
It's a lot of this.
that's good yeah really yeah and then vocal straws i use straws it's about like i mean we could get
teckers if you want but it's about getting your larynx to drop back down like they're putting your
tongue at the back of your throat and opening your palate with a straw literally with a straw
and then the straw the straw helps with back pressure so you blow bubbles into a into a bottle through a
straw and then the back pressure helps open that up and easel that out it's like a little
对，有的。这叫“企鹅噪音”。就是发出很多这种声音。这挺好的，真的，对。然后是声乐吸管，我用吸管。这大概是——我的意思是，如果你想听的话我们可以讲得很技术流——但这主要是为了让你的喉头降回原位，就像把你的舌头抵在喉咙后方，用一根吸管打开你的软腭，字面意义上就是用一根吸管。然后吸管能产生背压，所以你通过吸管往瓶子里吹气泡，这种背压有助于把这里打开并舒缓开。这就像是一个小小的
reverse massage do you ever actually do you ever accidentally throw up do you ever accidentally throw up
when you're doing it i i can't eat like four hours before we go on stage because then bits come up
yeah yeah yeah because it's all quite shouty you know yeah yeah that's why i'm just you accidentally
throw up after a lot of big meals don't you yeah oh oh darn it but i hold his hair i hold his hair i've got to
get it out inside 10 minutes, otherwise it starts to absorb the fat.
So, Marcus, Marcus, we're a month into your tour.
What will have been the most important part of your prep to go on some long tour?
Like, do you have to get, you know, your family stuff all in order so that it can withstand you being gone so long long?
反向按摩。你有没有试过在做这个的时候不小心吐出来？你有没有在做这个的时候不小心吐出来过？我上台前四个小时左右绝对不能吃东西，不然会有东西涌上来，是的，是的，因为这整个过程挺需要喊叫的，你知道的，对，对，这就是为什么我只是……你在吃了很多大餐之后也会不小心吐出来，对吧？噢，噢，该死。但我会抓着他的头发，我抓着他的头发。我必须在10分钟内把它吐出来，否则它就要开始吸收脂肪了。所以，马库斯，马库斯，你的巡演已经开始一个月了。为漫长的巡演做准备，最重要的一部分是什么？比如说，你是不是得把家里的事情都安排妥当，好让它经得起你长时间离家的考验？
Do you have to get your body in order
so it can withstand the hours?
What is prep for a long tour look at?
I have been trying to approach.
I got to a point a couple years ago,
I was like, there is an element of physicality to my job
that requires me to train a bit more.
So I have been working on that
你是不是得把身体状态调整好，好经得起那些小时数的折腾？漫长巡演的准备工作究竟是怎样的？我一直在尝试调整方法。几年前我达到了一个阶段，当时我想：我的工作确实包含一部分体力要求，这需要我做更多的体能训练。所以我一直在致力于此，
and trying to approach it more like an athletics program
and everything else will follow
if I can do that stuff well.
What are we looking at?
Cardio, we're pushing weight.
What's our terms?
training the play.
Yeah, all that stuff.
并试图把它当成一个田径项目来对待，只要我把这些基础做好，其他一切都会水到渠成。我们具体在练什么？有氧运动，我们在推重物。我们的术语是什么？训练演出状态。是的，所有这些。
Yeah, and then we have a little gym on the road that helps.
There's a lot of card.
Like singing, it turns out that singing playing guitar and stamping like this with your feet,
which you must remember, Jason, from that video.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, Jay was in the video.
So fun.
That stuff turns out is some sort of cardio.
是的，然后在巡演途中我们有一个小型健身房可以帮忙。有很多有氧运动。就像唱歌一样，事实证明，唱歌、弹吉他、用脚这样疯狂跺脚——杰森，你一定还记得那段视频。哦，对。对，杰就在那个视频里。太好玩了。事实证明，那些动作其实也是一种有氧运动。
I used to think it was enough to.
Yeah, it's exhausting.
Wait, talk about how did that happen?
How did Jason, how did Jason, how did Jason,
Baitman end up in your video.
Less disdain.
No, I spit it out.
How did fucking Jason Bateman end up.
我以前还以为这就足够了。是的，这太消耗体力了。等等，聊聊那是怎么发生的？杰森，杰森，杰森·贝特曼（Jason Bateman）怎么会参演你们的视频？少来点鄙视。不，我把它吐出来。该死的杰森·贝特曼怎么会……
It was all, it was a friend Sam Jones, wasn't it?
He called you.
Oh, yeah.
Or was it Sadecas?
I think maybe I was doing horrible bosses at the time.
Maybe it was, I'll bet you Sam contacted.
I didn't know Sam, so he wouldn't have contacted me.
So it would have been probably Sadecas or Ed or Will.
这一切全都是因为我们的朋友山姆·琼斯（Sam Jones），对吧？他给你打了电话。哦，对。还是萨代基斯（Sudeikis）？我想当时我可能在拍《恶老板》（Horrible Bosses）。也许是吧，我敢打赌是山姆联系的我。我不认识山姆，所以他不会联系我。所以那可能多半是萨代基斯、埃德（Ed）或者威廉（Will）干的。
Yeah.
And then they, I don't know how they got to me.
It must have got a lot of passes before they got to me.
But God, that was so fun.
Probably my favorite music video we've ever done
because I didn't have to do anything.
And I just got to watch you guys do it.
It was absolutely amazing.
是的。然后他们……我不知道他们是怎么找到我的。在联系到我之前，他们肯定发了很多张通行证（意指试过很多人选）。但天哪，那真的太好玩了。那可能是我最喜欢的我们拍过的音乐录影带，因为我什么都不用做。我只需要看着你们演。这简直太棒了。
Forte killed me on that.
Oh yeah, well, Farte was in.
With a kiss, the kiss.
The kiss, the hard kiss.
All right, so that brings us to Sam.
That brings us to the dock.
Let's talk about the dock.
Let's talk about the train tour.
福尔特（Forte）在里面把我笑死了。哦对，福尔特也在里面。那个吻，那个吻。那个吻，那个充满力量的吻。好吧，那么这把我们引向了山姆。这把我们引向了这部纪录片。我们来聊聊纪录片吧。来聊聊那次火车巡演。
Let's talk about you arranging.
for those other groups
because you spoke earlier about picking
the bands that you guys
are interfacing with.
Well, let's go in order.
What's it like traveling on a train that long
with that many people?
来聊聊你为那些其他乐队做音乐编排的事，因为你刚才说过要挑选你们要合作的乐队。好吧，我们按顺序来。坐那么久的火车，跟那么多人一起旅行是什么感觉？
It's really exhausting.
I don't recommend it.
It's very confined.
It's like being on a submarine.
It's worse than a tour bus.
Right.
And I mean, it was the most...
Sorry, tell the audience what the basic concept of this thing.
真的超级累。我不推荐。空间非常局促。就像待在一艘潜艇里。比巡演大巴还要糟糕。没错。我的意思是，那是最……抱歉，给观众讲讲这东西的基本概念吧。
And it was inspired by the...
This happened, Woody Guthrie.
and gang, right?
Yeah, I think they did it.
Basically, someone came to us, you know,
I don't know, 2011 and said,
we have access to a bunch of vintage rail cars.
Do you want to go on tour on a train?
它的灵感来源于……这事以前发生过，伍迪·格思里（Woody Guthrie）和他的伙伴们，对吧？对，我想他们以前这么干过。基本上，有人在2011年左右找到我们，说：我们搞到了一批老式铁路车厢，你们想不想坐火车去巡演？
Yeah.
And we, at that point, we're like,
we'd just done a tour of India.
Yeah.
Well before we had any reason to do a tour of India.
You know, we'd toured on a narrow boat.
We liked putting up our own festivals.
It was just, like, fun ways of, like,
对。然后在那个时候，我们觉得：我们刚刚做完一次印度巡演。对。早在我们有任何理由去印度巡演之前。你知道的，我们曾在窄底船上巡演。我们喜欢自己办音乐节。这只是让事情感觉稍微有点不同、
making the shit feel slightly different.
and discovering bits of the world
that you might not otherwise.
So we were feeling adventurous
and we said, yes, we did it with Edward Sharp
and the Magnetic Zeros.
With old Crow Medicine show
and it was the best week on the road we've ever had.
并且去探索你可能不会发现的世界角落的有趣方式。所以我们当时很有冒险精神，然后我们说：好。我们和爱德华·夏普与磁性零点乐队（Edward Sharpe and the Magnetic Zeros）一起完成了这次巡演。还有老乌鸦药物秀（Old Crow Medicine Show），那绝对是我们经历过的最棒的一周巡演。
And we made a film and it won a Grammy
and we were all very happy.
It was great.
And so we thought, let's run it back
slightly differently.
Let's get all our favorite musicians
together as a house band.
And then every night we'll get special guests
我们还拍了一部电影，它赢得了一座格莱美奖，我们当时都非常高兴。这太棒了。所以我们想：让我们换一种稍微不同的方式再来一次。把我们所有最喜欢的音乐人聚在一起当驻场乐队。然后每天晚上我们都会邀请特别嘉宾
to come on stage with us.
So we had Lainey, Wilson,
Harris, Rucker, Maggie Rogers, and Noah Kahn.
And we learned their songs the day before.
Wow.
And performed like the house band for them.
And it was really fun.
And we did it.
上台跟我们一起表演。所以我们请来了莱妮·威尔逊（Lainey Wilson）、达里乌斯·拉克尔（Darius Rucker）、玛吉·罗杰斯（Maggie Rogers）和诺亚·卡恩（Noah Kahan）。我们甚至在演出前一天才学会他们的歌。哇。然后像他们的专属乐队一样进行表演。这真的太有趣了。我们做到了。
Yeah, we traveled by train.
But that's not really the audience participation part,
because obviously it was just us and crew that went on the trains.
But it was only five days.
So it was manageable.
But it was exhausting.
But you've got Sam and his gang with the cameras in there documenting the, yeah?
Yeah, so Sam made this film for it, which I really love, actually.
是的，我们是坐火车出行的。但这并不是真正的观众参与环节，因为很明显，坐火车的只有我们和工作人员。但这只有五天时间。所以还在掌控之中。不过确实很累。但山姆和他的摄影师团队也在里面把这些记录下来了，对吧？对，所以山姆为此拍了这部电影，其实我真的很喜欢。
I don't enjoy the process of making music films.
I think in general they're quite boring, and I don't really watch them for pleasure.
And this one...
It can feel like a reality show, right?
Yeah, a little bit.
And, yeah, I find it quite hard to relate to a lot of them.
Obviously, the Beatles one is my favorite of all time, and I've watched that many times.
But other than that, I don't get a huge amount of enjoyment from watching.
我不喜欢制作音乐电影的过程。我觉得它们通常都很无聊，我平时也不会为了消遣去看它们。而这部……它有时会感觉像是一个真人秀，对吧？对，有点像。而且，是的，我觉得很难和其中很多内容产生共鸣。很显然，披头士的那部是我有史以来最喜欢的，我看过很多次。但除此之外，看这些并不能带给我极大的乐趣。
This one, especially not our ones.
But this one, I actually think he did something really beautiful with,
and the people involved were unbelievably kind with their time.
We made it kind of like a socialistic enterprise.
Everyone got paid the same,
and whatever cash there was left in the pot
after very expensive trains, we just shared out.
And then our friends really gave us their time, you know,
这部不会，尤其是关于我们自己的那些。但这部电影，我真的觉得他在里面加入了一些非常美妙的东西，而且参与其中的人们在时间上慷慨得难以置信。我们把它做成了一种类似社会主义性质的企业。每个人拿同样的酬劳，在支付了昂贵的火车费用后，锅里还剩多少现金，我们就平分。然后我们的朋友们真的把时间毫无保留地给了我们，你知道的，
and they're phenomenal musicians, and we had it a working time.
I was going to say for Tracy,
but she knows because she met Sam
when we went to her. Sam Jones is the same guy
who did the Smartless on the road
special that we did.
So that's how we all know Sam
through the process.
而且他们都是杰出的音乐人，我们度过了一段高效的工作时间。我正想提到翠西（Tracy），因为她知道，当我们在她那儿时她遇到了山姆。山姆·琼斯就是那个制作了我们拍的《聪明满分》（SmartLess）巡演特别节目的导演。所以这就是我们所有人通过这个过程认识山姆的经历。
Yeah, that's so cool.
I didn't know he did this
and I didn't know anything about this.
When can we see it?
And I'd made a film with him before.
He made the documentary about the new basement tapes thing
that we did with Elvis Costello
and Jim James and Taylor Bosman.
对，太酷了。我甚至不知道他拍了这个，我对这事一无所知。我们什么时候能看到它？我以前跟他合作拍过一部电影。他制作了关于我们和埃尔维斯·科斯特洛（Elvis Costello）、吉姆·詹姆斯（Jim James）以及泰勒·博斯曼（Taylor Goldsmith）一起做的“新地下室磁带”（New Basement Tapes）项目的纪录片。
Oh, I don't know about this.
Yeah, and Giddens.
We took old Bob Dylan lyrics
that Tebow and Burnett had like pilfered off Dylan.
and asked if we could record music for them
and Dylan amazingly said yes
they were literally from shoe boxes
and the Big Pink from the 60s
哦，我不知道这个。是的，还有吉登斯（Giddens）。我们采用了鲍勃·迪伦（Bob Dylan）那些未曾发表的旧歌词，那些由 T·邦恩·伯内特（T Bone Burnett）从迪伦那里搜罗来的旧词，
and so we wrote music to all these unused lyrics
which was really fun
and Sam made a documentary of that
so I'd worked with him before
and obviously he shot our Rolling Stone cover
which I hate but he also made that Hopeless Wanderer video
that Jason was in so we'd work with him a bit before
and he came on and did it and it was sweet
然后问我们能不能为它们谱曲。迪伦非常惊讶地答应了。它们真的是从20世纪60年代“大粉红”（Big Pink）的鞋盒子里翻出来的。
and he also made the Wilco Dock
I'm trying to break your heart
Yeah, which is also amazing.
It's so great.
It's so good.
I want to see that talk you were just talking about.
I want to see that one where you guys with the diligence.
Oh, it's sweet.
所以我们为所有这些未使用的歌词谱了曲，这真的很有趣，山姆把这拍成了一部纪录片，所以我以前跟他合作过。很显然他还拍了我们的《滚石》杂志封面，虽然我很讨厌那张照片；但他还导演了杰森参演的那个《绝望的流浪者》（Hopeless Wanderer）MV，所以我们之前就跟他合作过好多次了。他这次来拍了这部片子，真的很温馨。
Yeah, it was a while ago.
Yeah, too, actually.
Go ahead, Cheney.
I was just going to do my standard, like,
do you have any like one show or one fan interaction on stage
that just went horribly wrong,
or something that went horribly wrong on stage during a tour?
Yeah, yeah, recently.
而且他还拍了杰克（Wilco）乐队的纪录片《我试图击碎你的心》（I Am Trying to Break Your Heart），对吧，那部也很棒。太伟大了。太棒了。我想看你刚才说的那部纪录片。我想看你们坐着马车的那个。哦，那部很温馨。
We started the Prize Fighter tour in Australia.
Yeah.
And we played a song for the first time
and it went so badly wrong,
we stopped halfway through,
and we didn't start the song again.
No way.
I love that, though.
对，那是好久以前的事了。是的，其实也有点久了。请说，切尼。我正想问我那个标准的经典问题：你有没有经历过哪怕只有一次演出，或者在舞台上跟某个粉丝的互动，结果变得糟糕透顶？或者在巡演期间，有什么事在舞台上搞砸了？有啊，最近就发生过。
Oh, my God, I love that.
What did you say?
I said, that's live music, folks, and we moved on.
And I wanted to fall through the floor so badly.
It was the worst, I think it was the worst moment I've ever, ever had on.
Why did you stop?
Oh, it was just a disaster.
Everyone was in the wrong key and wrong time.
我们在澳大利亚开始了“奖金猎人”巡演。对。我们第一次现场演奏一首歌，结果搞砸得太厉害了，我们演到一半直接停了下来，而且没有重新把那首歌再弹一遍。不会吧。不过我挺喜欢这样的。
Oh, wow.
a disaster and would have required a full rehearsal to do it.
And I thought that was probably pushing it.
So we just stopped and moved on to one there.
And you just thought, we'll get this, we'll get this, watch this, six, seven, eight.
It was awful. It was so horrible.
I'll bet you the audience loved it though, like kind of, you know, like a blooper.
Yeah, that's so cool.
天哪，我太喜欢了。你当时说了什么？我说：这就是现场音乐，各位。然后我们就继续了。当时我真恨不得直接从舞台地板缝里掉下去。这绝对是我这辈子经历过的最糟糕、最糟糕的演出时刻。你们为什么停下来？哦，简直是一场灾难。每个人都不在同一个调上，节奏也全乱了。
Yeah, I think, you know, yeah, my wife says things like, because I forget lyrics a lot.
When I get nervous, my memory goes, and I'll forget a lyric sometimes, and she'll be like,
that's the bit people love.
Yeah. That's the live bit as different to the original.
record and...
I toured with Kenny Rogers when I was in my early 20s
as a Christmas elf in his tour.
Amazing.
哦，哇。简直是一场灾难，要重新排练一遍才能演好。我觉得那样做可能有点强人所难。所以我们索性停下，直接进入下一首了。然后你当时心里想的是：我们会搞定的，看这个，六，七，八。太可怕了。简直糟糕透顶。我敢打赌观众一定很喜欢这样，就好像看了一场花絮一样，挺酷的。
And he would forget the lyrics all the time.
And whenever he did, he would just hold the microphone out to the audience.
You got to know when.
I thought...
Sean, I thought you'd go, hey, Santa, the lyric is.
Yeah, shuffle over like a little helpful elf.
Hey, have you ever done that on stage, though?
Because that's, that terrifies, especially with a one-man show.
对，我觉得，你知道的，我老婆总是会说这样的话，因为我经常忘词。当我紧张的时候，我的记忆力就会崩溃，有时会忘词，她就会说：这才是人们最喜欢的部分。是的。这才是现场版和原版录音的不同之处，而且……我在20多岁时曾跟肯尼·罗杰斯（Kenny Rogers）一起巡演，在他的巡演里扮演一个圣诞小精灵。太神了。
Have you ever forgotten your lives?
Yeah, yeah.
There's one, I just did it.
It's absolutely terrifying.
There is one part where the line is, you know, I say to one of the characters, I say,
are you going to be here?
How long are you in town for?
And he says, the weekend.
他总是忘词。每当他忘词时，他就会把麦克风直接递给观众。你得知道什么时候该递。我当时想……肖恩，我还以为你会说：嘿，圣诞老人，歌词是这样的。对，像个热心的小精灵一样碎步挪过去。嘿，你在舞台上有过这种经历吗？因为这太吓人了，特别是对独角戏演员来说。
I say, can we get together and discuss this one thing?
He says, sure.
And then I say, your last name is DuPain.
And then one night I go, is one of the characters.
I go, how long are you in town for?
He goes, the weekend.
And I go, can we get together?
and I go
你曾经忘过台词吗？有啊，有啊。有一次，我刚刚才经历过。简直太吓人了。其中有一幕，台词是这样的，你知道的，我对其中一个角色说：你打算在这儿待多久？你在城里待几天？然后他说：就这个周末。
to myself
I go wait how long
are you in town for
to the character
and I go
I just told you
我说：我们能不能聚一聚，讨论一下这件小事？他说：当然可以。然后我说：你姓杜潘（DuPain）。结果有一天晚上，我冲着其中一个角色说：你在城里待几天？他回答：就这个周末。然后我说：我们能聚一聚吗？接着我说
I'm in town
just for the weekend
and it bought me time
to think of what line was next
and did you get there
yeah thank God
and do you think people noticed
no they don't fucking know
我自己在心里嘀咕：等等，我问那个角色你在城里待几天，而我刚才明明已经告诉他了
yeah
and certainly the stage manager
that was asleep in the wings
not throwing you the line
didn't notice
either, right?
Right, yeah.
They just watch.
我只在城里待到周末。这为主意争取了时间，让我去想接下来该接哪句台词。你当时想起来了吗？对，谢天谢地。你觉得观众注意到了吗？没有，他们他妈的根本不知道。
The living daylight's happening.
Yeah, it is pretty good.
All right, before we let you go, because we're two minutes over here, I want to know how
being a parent has changed the way that you, that you listen to music or write music.
I'm assuming they go with you a little bit, but it's got to change the way you are as an artist,
as a musician, yes?
Yeah.
Yeah, I think it's, I think it's been a healthy, I think it's been a wonderful antidote to my
而且在侧幕条里睡着、没给你提词的舞台经理肯定也没注意到，对吧？对，没错。他们只是在旁边看着。
narcissism.
because you can't just
you can't just be the cent
I mean you probably can
but I found it difficult
to remain the centre of my universe
with these little ones around
and it puts everything else in perspective
看着活生生的现实在上演。对，这确实挺带劲的。好了，在我们让你离开之前——因为我们已经超时两分钟了——我想知道，为人父母是如何改变你听音乐或写音乐的方式的？我猜他们偶尔会跟你一起巡演，但这肯定改变了你作为艺术家、作为音乐人的状态，对吧？是的。是的。我觉得，它是一种健康的、美妙的解药，
in such a helpful way for me
I've found it
so if you're asking about how it's
how it's affected my work
it makes me more intentional when I go to work
and actually scheduling wise
I just want our team to pack as much
as they can into as short a period of time as possible.
用来对付我的自恋。因为你不能——你不可能永远只成为中——我的意思是，你可能确实可以，但当这些小家伙们在身边时，我发现自己很难继续成为自己宇宙的中心，它以一种对我非常有帮助的方式，把其他所有事情都放回了正确的视角中。如果你问我是如何影响我的工作的，它让我去工作时更有意图性。而且在日程安排上，我只想让我们的团队在尽可能短的时间内塞满尽可能多的工作。
So I'll go away and I'll work really, really hard for whatever period of time I'm away,
and then I'd come home and sooner than I would have, if the schedule had been more easy, you know?
And I would imagine when you do come home, that is the thing you are most addicted to
completely indulging in, right?
You are rationally excited to just like dive headfirst into family.
Yeah, I want to get home, you know, like one of the guys really likes,
doing the day,
I just want to get home
所以我离开家去工作时会非常非常努力，无论离开多久，然后我会回家，比日程安排得更轻松时要更快地回到家，你知道吗？我能想象，当你回到家时，那绝对是你最渴望全身心纵情投入的事情，对吧？你理所当然地渴望一头扎进家庭生活中。是的，我想回家，你知道的，就像其中一个家伙真的很喜欢度过日常时光一样，我只想尽快回家，
as soon as possible
I don't care which flight it is
and then hopefully be there
for the school run the morning after
because, and that's why
dropping booze for me
has been so helpful,
it's just made my life more functional.
我才不管坐哪趟航班呢。然后希望第二天早上就能赶上送孩子去上学。这也是为什么对我来说戒酒如此有帮助，因为它让我的生活恢复了正常功能。
Get up earlier.
Because I get home, I'm not dusty.
You know, I'm like,
yeah, it's just being like present
as fast as you can
in an accelerated manner, it feels like.
So it's made me more present, I think.
Yeah, yeah.
起得更早。因为我回到家时，神志清醒，没有宿醉。你知道的，那种感觉就像是：是的，这能让你以一种加速的方式尽快在场。所以它让我变得更加活在当下，我觉得。是的，是的。
And then more grateful when I get to go
and do my work and
go and play these shows.
I just feel grateful for it. I'm in this
season of gratitude with the band that I'm just
really enjoying because I'll go
away and be like, I've got to make the absolute
most of this because it's
然后当我能够去工作、去进行这些演出时，我会更加心怀感激。我对这一切只有感激。我和乐队现在正处于一个感恩的季节，我真的很享受这种状态，因为当我离开时，我会想：我必须充分利用这一切，因为这
awesome and it's amazing. It's such a privilege
and our audience have been so
kind to us and continue to grow and
that's just felt like
wild and so I want to
be really good. I want to be really
great at that and that takes
time and attention that
太棒了、太不可思议了。这真是一种特权，我们的观众对我们这么好，而且还在不断成长。这一切感觉就像做梦一样疯狂，所以我想要表现得非常好。我想要在这方面做到顶尖，而这需要时间和注意力，
obviously is a cost balance, you know.
But I'm just attacking it.
Well, you are, you want to read out and work.
Sorry, Jay, I was just going to say, like, I've gone through that too in the last couple of years.
It's like if you are going to do something that's taking you away from home and the kids and all this stuff, it's got to be valuable.
Exactly.
And if you're going to do it, you do it wholeheartedly.
And then you go, because you really just want to be home.
这显然需要付出代价进行权衡，你知道的。但我正在全力以赴。好吧，你想重申并投入工作。抱歉，杰，我只是想说，过去几年里我也经历过这种转变。这就好像如果你要做一件事，会让你离开家、离开孩子和所有这些事情，那它必须是有价值的。没错。如果你打算去做，就要全心全意地去做。然后你就可以离开了，因为你内心深处其实只想回家。
Right.
So it's got to be meaningful.
Well, we're grateful of the time you do spend
away from them because you are incredible at it.
Keep going at it.
And maybe we'll see you for the doc down the street.
I will see you.
With my wife.
所以这必须是有意义的。好吧，我们非常感谢你抽出不陪伴他们的时间来参加节目，因为你表现得太棒了。继续加油吧。也许我们在街上的纪录片首映礼上还能见到你。我会见到你的。带着我我老婆。
The woman he'll be with is my wife.
And I want a full report, Marcus.
Take some pictures for me.
I'm really excited to see you guys.
Yeah.
Thanks so much for having me.
Oh, thank you.
for doing this.
跟他在一起的那位女士就是我老婆。我想要一份完整的报告，马库斯。帮我拍点照片。我真的很高兴能见到你们。好的，非常感谢邀请我。哦，谢谢你抽空做这期节目。
Privilege.
Oh, man.
We're such fans.
Enjoy the rest of your day, Val.
Thank you, see you guys.
Okay, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye.
That was double M, as I like to call him.
Double M&M.
这是我的荣幸。哦，天哪。我们真是你的超级粉丝。祝你今天余下的时间过得愉快，瓦尔。谢谢，再见，各位。好的，拜拜，拜拜，拜拜，拜拜。刚才那是双M，正如我喜欢叫他的那样。双M。
I call him M&M.
It was great.
By the way, isn't that crazy
that at the beginning, we were talking about our hair
and you said, what's the name of your new hairdresser?
And I said, Marcos.
No, it's not.
Marcos.
我叫他M&M。太棒了。顺便说一句，不觉得很疯狂吗，一开始我们聊到我们的头发，你问，你新发型师叫什么名字？我说，马科斯。不对，不是。马科斯。
Marcos Mumford.
Yeah, I just,
I just don't think that's Mark.
And then the guest name was Mark.
Well, it's M-I-R-C-O-S.
So it's the same.
I get where you're going with this, Sean.
But, you know, it's not, it's not fucking nuts.
马科斯·芒福德。对，我只是，我只是不觉得那是马克。然后嘉宾的名字是马克。好吧，它是 M-I-R-C-O-S。所以是一样的。肖恩，我懂你的意思。但是，你知道，这根本不他妈的疯狂。
It's not crazy.
No.
I think that's really wild.
I mean, what are the odds of that?
What are the odds?
He's great, though.
I mean...
Chat TB-T, what are the odds?
这并不可疯狂。不。我觉得这真的很离谱。我的意思是，几率有多大？几率有多大？不过他很棒。我是说……Chat TB-T，几率有多大？
He is great.
That I didn't, you know, I never knew anything about him.
I like, I really like his...
flavor of British accent.
Yeah, me too.
I noticed that too, and I like that too.
It's melodious.
Yeah, it's nice.
他真的很棒。我以前，你知道的，我对他一无所知。我喜欢，我真的很喜欢他的……那种英国口音的腔调。是的，我也是。我也注意到了，我也很喜欢。很动听。是的，挺不错的。
It's calming.
There are definitely different regions of the British accent.
Oh, which ones aren't there, Jason?
There's sort of the aristocratic sound.
There's the Liverpadlian, there's the slightly Scottish, there's the Welsh, right?
Will, Will, you're the guy over there.
How dare you?
Oh, very dear, yeah.
很安抚人心。英国口音确实有不同的地区之分。哦，杰森，有哪些是没听过的？有那种贵族腔。有利物浦腔，有轻微的苏格兰腔，有威尔士腔，对吧？威尔，威尔，你才是那边的专家。你怎么敢？哦，天哪，对。
Right?
And, like, I wouldn't be...
You're okay.
You're right, Jason.
Yeah, see?
You can't just do a regular British accent
对吧？而且，就像，我不会……你没事吧。你没事。你没事。你说得对，杰森。对吧？你不能只用普通的英国口音
if you're going to play a character.
It's got to be region-specific.
Yep.
He's such a nice dude.
I'm really excited for the doc.
I can't wait to see it.
I didn't know anything about it.
Yeah, yeah.
如果你要演一个角色的化。它必须是特定地区的。没错。他真是个好人。我真的很期待这部纪录片。我等不及要看了。我之前对此一无所知。对，对。
It's going to be really good.
What time are you going to pick my wife up?
And what are you going to wear?
Well, she's spending the night,
so I think that we're going to...
Hang on.
We're going to be, we'll just get ready together, you know.
By the way, I was just talking to her right before this.
一定会非常精彩。你几点去接我妻子？你打算穿什么？嗯，她要在这过夜，所以我想我们……等等。我们要去，我们一起准备就行了，你知道的。顺便说一句，就在这之前我刚跟她通过电话。
She says, hello, Jason.
Oh, yeah, I've not spoken to her yet today.
You guys really do more time on the phone than me.
We can decide if we want to cut this.
I said, are we doing dinner on Sunday?
She goes, I'm not sure.
And if we don't do dinner, I go, well, we can get dinner.
She goes, no, if we're not doing dinner with all of us getting together,
她说，你好，杰森。哦，对，我今天还没跟她说过话。你们俩通电话的时间真的比我还多。我们可以决定要不要剪掉这段。我说，我们周日吃晚饭吗？她说，我不确定。如果我们不吃晚饭，我说，那我们可以去吃晚饭。她说，不，如果我们不大家一起聚聚吃晚饭的话，
I'm doing a full moon women's circle, L.O.L.
Hold your tongue.
Full moon, women's circle.
There is some kind of a full, full light bulb up in the sky coming up here soon.
How about that?
Wait, and what are you doing the circle?
I'll call her.
I don't know.
我要去参加一个满月女性圆桌聚会，大笑。住口。满月，女性圆桌聚会。天空中不久将会有某种满月、满月灯泡要升起来了。怎么样？等等，你在那个圆桌聚会上做什么？我给她打电话。我不知道。
Maybe I'll do that.
Yeah, we'll trim this.
All right.
Who's got a buy?
Anybody got a buy?
Wait, didn't I try to start something new last week?
If we ever did a week where we didn't throw out a buy, we would have to call that the
Bye week.
也许我会这么做。好吧，我们会把这剪掉的。好了。谁有推荐的好物？有人有什么推荐吗？等等，我上周是不是想开始一个新花样？如果我们有哪周没有推荐好物，我们就得把那周叫做“轮空周”（Bye week）。
The bye week we get a bye.
I don't need to keep saying it.
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett, Barbico, and Michael Grant Terry.
Smartless.
“轮空周”，我们轮空一次。我不用一直说这个了。Smartless 是百分之百有机且由 Rob Armjurf、Bennett、Barbico 和 Michael Grant Terry 手工制作的。Smartless。